Ja, nicht weil ich wirklich gedacht hätte, dass das funktioniert.
Davon habe ich gesagt, es gibt keine Tabelle, die Keckweh heißt.
Einfach nur so, weil es geht.
Ich mache eigentlich fast jeden Tag was.
Gestern hatte ich mal wieder einen Tag Pause.
Mist, habe ich das Archiv gelöscht?
Ja klar, mit dem Archiv muss ich ja an meiner Namensgebung orientieren.
Und meine Dateien heißen ja auch immer Keckweh, Temp, Plupp und sonst was.
Nein, vor allem, ich will nicht updaten.
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Kannst du die nächste Bombe auf Twitter zünden?
Du meinst Influencer-Beef-Bombe, was da gerade wieder abgeht?
Also, ich glaube, da bin ich nicht mehr in der Lage.
Oh, guck mal, der Pepo ist schon im Bett, weil es 1937 ist.
Da glaube ich, kann ich nicht mehr dazu beitragen heutzutage.
Ich bin da nicht mehr aktiv genug auf YouTube zu.
Außerdem kenne ich von den ganzen Leuten, wo es wert wäre, die kenne ich alle gar nicht.
Tropf was über den Fabian.
Ja, geil.
Weil ich mich auch gerade mit dem Frasier beefen will.
Und vor allem, wen juckt das heute noch, wenn wir das machen würden?
Da müssen wir mal zumindest irgendjemand drauf haben, der darauf reactet.
Dass das ein bisschen größer rauskommt, ja.
Oh, Curdle-Update.
Das heißt gleich wieder Reboot.
Ruby.
Was?
Anni de Dac, als ist das noch interessant.
Max, das ist out.
Ich habe gehört, Unge vs. Ex-Freundin ist jetzt angesagt.
Und jetzt droppt auch noch iBlali was dazu, habe ich gehört.
Naja, dass da jeden Tag was Neues...
Leute, auch wenn es sich jetzt vielleicht so angehört hat, als würde ich irgendwie...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich los ist.
Null.
Ich weiß das nur, weil mir das jemand auf Twitter geschrieben hat.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Was hat denn der Nico wieder angestellt?
Ja, stimmt, da war ja auch was.
Moment.
Was war bei MontanaBlack nochmal?
Ah, dass er irgendeine junge Freundin hat oder sowas, gell?
Wobei ich mir da denke, wie gesagt, ich habe von nichts großartig was mitgekriegt.
Wobei ich mir da denke, wahrscheinlich hätten die meisten Leute, die da drüber rumflamen, auch gerne eine junge Freundin.
So, CurlUp, der Reboot.
Es ist jeden Tag irgendwas, ohne Mist.
Und wisst ihr, also eine Sache verstört mich ja persönlich.
Moment, das ist doch...
War das nicht schon letztes Jahr irgendwann mal Thema, was mich ja ein bisschen verstört ist.
Also das Influencer...
Das Influencer-Beef und so, das ist mir ja schon seit Jahren gewohnt.
Jetzt haben wir hier Update, Update.
Ach, guck mal, Rust Rover ist non-commercial use jetzt free.
Das heißt, dafür müsste ich gar kein Abo haben.
Gut, aber für Rider und Go-Land brauche ich schon mal ein Abo.
Als würde es irgendjemand heutzutage jucken, was ich sage, man.
Aber was mich ja ein bisschen wundert, bei dieser ganzen Influencer-Beef-Geschichte,
immer, was für einen Scheiß mittlerweile alles öffentlich auf Twitter...
Sorry, auf X natürlich, nicht auf Twitter.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Oder auf...
Was habe ich letztens gehört in der Präsentation?
Xitter.
Also, was...
Ich fand nicht eigentlich ganz gut, so können wir das jetzt hin.
Was auf Xitter neuerdings so gemacht wird.
Also, was mich da immer echt super verstört ist,
wie öffentlich das teilweise ausgetragen wird.
Und da geht es ja oftmals nicht mal...
Ich meine jetzt nichts Konkretes, nur ganz allgemein.
Da geht es ja oftmals gar nicht um irgendwelche weltbewegenden Sachen,
so nach dem Motto, da, irgendwie, die CIA hört uns ab,
damit muss man jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit oder so.
Das ist ja meistens so belangloser Kram, wo sich die Leute,
vielleicht will ich es ja nicht gut heißen,
wo sich die Leute vielleicht mal früher, wenn sie sich über den Weg gelaufen sind,
gekloppt haben oder sich mal irgendwie angeschrien wurde.
Oder mal privat ein bisschen gelästert wurde.
Und das war gut.
Aber das wird heute wirklich super breit zelebriert auf Twitter, auf Xitter.
Und da sind halt so Dinger drin.
Da liest du dann irgendwelche Posts, so nach dem Motto,
ja, vor fünf Jahren hat mich Influencer XY angeschrieben
und ich habe ja bis heute stillgehalten,
aber ich trage es seit fünf Jahren mit mir herum.
Und ich halte es einfach nicht mehr aus.
Es macht mich seelisch kaputt.
Und dann wird da drüber geschrieben,
vor fünf Jahren hat dieser Influencer mir eine PN geschrieben,
obwohl ich explizit gesagt habe, ich will keine PN.
Und hat geschrieben, dein Video ist scheiße.
Und das...
Das ist doch Dinger, wo ich mir denke, Alter...
So belangloses Zeug, Mann.
Ja, oder dann auch...
Ja, die Freundin von der Influencer-Freundin
hatte was mit dem anderen Influencer
und ich habe mitgekriegt, dass der zur gleichen Zeit fremdgegangen ist,
wo ich mir dann sage, what the fuck?
Warum muss man das öffentlich auf Twitter diskutieren?
Wen juckt's, Alter?
Wen juckt's?
Der Typ kann es meinetwegen mit halb YouTube treiben,
das geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Und wisst ihr, was mich auch immer ein bisschen...
Na, irritiert nicht, aber was ich dann auch immer lustig finde,
sobald es irgendeinen Beef gibt
zwischen irgendwelchen halbwegs bekannten Influencer-Dudes und Mädels,
da kommen dann Leute an den Start,
wo du dir so denkst,
ey, mehr als ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit abgreifen,
kann ich es mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen.
Da posten dann irgendwelche Leute so,
ja, ich habe gehört,
vor zwei Jahren war ich mal in einem Discord-Call
und da war der Influencer, der hat mir gesagt,
da war der Influencer auch drinne
und da hat er gesagt, ich mag keine Katzen oder...
Wobei, wird das nicht Unge sogar aktuell vorgeworfen?
Das habe ich irgendwo gelesen, dass Unge keine Katzen mag
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann, oh, und ich war so empört
und das fällt den Leuten dann wieder ein,
weil nach drei Jahren...
Meine Güte, ey, das ist alles echt so affig.
Aber vielleicht, Leute,
vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur
der Boomer, der aus mir spricht.
Vielleicht.
Ich bin einfach nicht mehr auf dem aktuellen Stand
und es interessiert mich auch nicht.
Es interessiert mich null.
Es interessiert mich null, ey.
Wobei, ich würde nicht sagen null,
ich würde vielleicht sagen so
0,000001 vielleicht.
Interessiert mich das.
Droptable-Influencer.
Soll ich den Stream...
Ja, der Foodplan, der muss nicht getroppt werden.
Das ist eh immer gleich.
Der ist hart gecodet, mein Foodplan.
Alter, ihr werdet es doch mal ertragen,
dass ich fünf Minuten was zum aktuellen...
Wie kann man das so schön...
Zeitgeschehen sage, ja?
Oder hättet ihr lieber, dass ich über Sylt rede?
Nee, will ich nicht.
Habe ich auch keinen Bock.
Außerdem geht mir das Thema eh schon wieder auf den Sack.
In alle Richtungen.
Ja, die Könnste, die Könnste...
Wobei, ich würde die Influencer vielleicht lieber überschreiben mit null.
Nicht moven nach null.
Lieber über 10++.
Nee, nee, nee, heute nicht, heute nicht, heute nicht.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung,
was für ein Elite das überhaupt sein soll.
Aber eine Sache wundert mich dabei ja immer.
Also, das hat ja auch schon bei...
Wie heißt, wie hieß dieses komische Schlager?
Das Schlagerlied, das sie geiler ist.
Was dann so super frauenfeindlich war.
Das hat ja auch nicht sonderlich gut funktioniert,
dass das in den Medien breit getreten wurde.
Danach hat es jeder gespielt und jeder gesungen.
Lach, lach, genau.
Danach hat es jeder gespielt und gesungen.
Manchmal ist es sogar im eigenen Interesse,
selbst wenn man was scheiße findet,
die Fresse zu halten.
Das macht es manchmal besser.
Auch wenn man echt...
Manchmal sich sagt, ey, nein, nein.
Aber manchmal ist es wirklich besser,
die Klappe zu halten,
selbst um seine eigenen Interessen zu verdrehen.
Ja, genau.
Max, morgen eine Fahrradtour beim...
Beim was?
Was soll das sein?
Ach, irgendein Fahrrad.
Ich habe keine Nachkunft nebenbei.
Irgendein Fahrrad...
Laden.
Also, ich bin eher, dass man die, wie gesagt,
nicht nach Null movet, sondern mit Null überschreibt.
Haben wir schon drüber geredet,
dass ein Secure abgeschaltet wird, ja.
Ja, aber guck mal, Leute.
Wenigstens eine erfreuliche Nachricht heute hier.
Der Mario darf Linux installieren aus seinem Arbeitsnotebook.
Das finde ich nice.
Excellent.
Was ich jetzt natürlich kacke finde
und weshalb ich dich jetzt eigentlich auch mal öffentlich
auf Twitter flamen müsste,
weil das ja gerade so...
Twitter flamen müsste, weil das ja auch angesagt ist.
Ich darf das nicht.
Und es ärgert mich.
Ich würde das auch gerne machen.
Glücklicherweise
habe ich mit meinem Windows-Notebook
nicht so viel zu tun, außer mich...
außer eine Konsole aufzumachen, um mich remote
auf meine Linux-Kiste einzuloggen.
Das ist legit das Einzige, was ich mache mit meiner Windows-Kiste.
Okay, den Browser
verwende ich manchmal für Zeiterfassung und sowas noch.
WSL? Nee, gibt kein WSL.
Es gibt noch nicht mal...
Ihr kennt doch hier unter Windows, gibt es doch diese
Clipboard-Historie. By the way, wer das nicht kennt,
Windows-Taste V, damit kann man die einschalten.
Ich habe die absichtlich nicht an,
wegen Streaming-Account.
Und sogar noch nicht mal das haben wir eingeschaltet.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum.
Ob das irgendeine komische Security-Policy ist?
Oder...
Oder unser Windows zu alt ist?
Ich behalte meine Social-Media-Accounts.
Ich sehe nicht ein, warum ich die löschen sollte.
Wozu? Man kann den meisten
Kram ignorieren, wenn man sein Heimatland
auf Andorra stellt.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich vorhin lustig ist?
Auf Hacker-News gesehen habe, muss ich euch mal kurz zeigen.
.NET
Da hat irgendeiner, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, was er gemacht hat,
aber zumindest kannst du mit .NET
Yes, äh, mit .NET
jetzt eine NES-Konsole
ansteuern.
Programm.cs
und das kannst du kompilieren dann
zu
einem lauffähigen
Binary für den NES.
Super abgedrehtes Zeug.
Visual Studio Code, ja.
Hat nicht jeder das
JetBrains All-Desktop-Abo.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was ich hier sehe.
Ich persönlich denke ja,
dass das einfach eine Library ist,
im Endeffekt, oder?
Oder ein Template?
Wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist.
Ich vermute im Endeffekt, dass es irgendeine Library ist
und, äh, mit
irgendeinem, ja,
mit irgendeinem Trick,
wo dann zur Compile-Zeit
dann NES-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung, wie es genau funktioniert, aber fand ich
eigentlich ganz lustig. Habe ich vorhin beim Durchscrollen
auf Hacker-News gesehen,
da muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Die DoubleTV, danke schön für den Sub.
Deine Blog,
die Blogliste, äh, ich habe so gut wie keine
Leute auf, auf
Xitter gebloggt.
Ich habe nur ein paar, also ich habe
jede Menge meine
Nacktbilder im Profil, Spam-Accounts,
gebloggt. Das ist ja auch gefühlt auf jede,
jeder Post hat mittlerweile
meine Nacktbilder im Profil von irgendeinem
Bot als Antwort. Ganz viele gebloggt.
Ich habe sonst wirklich kaum
Leute gebloggt. Ich will nicht sagen, dass
ich gar keinen gebloggt habe, weil das stimmt nicht. Ich habe sicherlich
mal die ein oder andere wirklich super
Abpack-Leute, die
mich genervt haben, gebloggt. Aber ich
habe auf Twitter noch nie jemand gebloggt,
weil mir was nicht gefallen hat, was er auf
seiner Timeline geschrieben hat.
Ich habe eigentlich bisher nur Leute
gebloggt, die wirklich persönlich irgendwas gegen mich
gesagt haben.
Weil ich denke mir da immer,
sollen die Leute halt auf ihrer Timeline
schreiben, was sie wollen?
Ich muss das ja nicht followen. Zur Not kann
ich sogar muten und da ist der Twitter-Algorithmus
sogar ganz gut drin, um mir die Leute nicht mehr anzuzeigen.
Also, oder, oder Content
ignoren.
Nur weil Leute irgendwas schreiben, was
mir nicht gefällt, blocke ich keinen auf Twitter.
Natürlich in Grenzen.
Sagen wir mal so, es gibt
sicherlich Sachen, da ist auch
meine Grenze
überschritten, da ich sage, ey,
das geht mir so und das will ich auf gar keinen Fall
irgendwie mal wieder angezeigt haben, dann würde ich auch jemanden
blocken. Aber ich habe vielleicht
in den ganzen Jahren, wo ich auf Twitter bin,
habe ich, keine Ahnung, 20 Leute gebloggt
oder so. Ohne die
ganzen Spam und meine
Nacktbilder im Profil-Account.
Übrigens, Windows hat mir
eben echt den übelsten Schreck eingejagt.
Ich habe ja auf meiner Vorschau-Rechner,
also den Rechner, den ich hier links
neben mir stehen habe, den ihr jetzt
nicht seht, da habe ich auf Windows 10
und ich habe mich eingeloggt
und auf einmal denke ich mir
so aus dem Augenwinkel, ich gucke auf den anderen Monitor,
denke mir so aus dem Augenwinkel, irgendwie
sieht mein Desktop komisch aus.
Und dann
gucke ich dahin, dann steht dann da,
ist irgendwie sowas wie a new
journey
begins
oder sowas, Windows.
Ob es da von
irgendwelchen... Ja!
The fuck? Ja, genau hier.
The Takumi
Morita war da am Start.
Im Fullscreen!
Auf dem zweiten Monitor, ich denke mir so, Alter!
Ist Recovery-Modus, ist mein
Rechner im Arsch?
Oder hat Windows ohne Mist
Fullscreen-Werbung für Windows 11
angezeigt? Ich habe mich
übelst erschreckt.
Ich habe gedacht, das Ding ist...
im Arsch. Dann habe ich mal Escape
ein paar Mal gedrückt, dann ging das wieder weg.
Aber was? Also...
Microsoft fuckt mich schon echt
ab mit sowas.
Mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert,
hätte jetzt das heiße Forum geschrieben.
Da hätte es ja nicht Unrecht gehabt.
Warum Copilot Screenshots
von einem PC machen?
Was?
Das will doch Microsoft jetzt auch.
Mit irgendeiner komischen...
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, habe ich letztens irgendeine News dazu gelesen.
Mit irgendeiner...
Mit irgendeiner Spezial-Hardware, wo Windows draufläuft,
wo die dann alles mögliche Screenshotten
und sogar Konferenzen, äh, Meetings
und so, Online-Meetings in Teams
mitschneiden.
Windows 10 ist 2014...
Ja! Na, deswegen ist doch klar,
deswegen muss man jetzt mit 2024
schon mal rumspammen.
Was aber nicht wild ist, ich werde das Ding einfach
auf Windows 11 upgraden und gut ist,
sobald's
dann
ansteht, dass es End of Life ist.
Was?
Hab ich schon Package-Updates gemacht?
Ja, ich hab schon Package-Updates gemacht
und ich hab sogar schon neu gestartet.
Windows 10 Support EOL.
Gibt's denn da...
Wie heißt das?
Äh...
Lifecycle oder so?
Ja.
Also, Windows 10 Home und Pro.
Wird supported?
Kann ich das...
Deaktivierungszeitraum?
Das ist mal, glaube ich, wieder richtig hängen geblieben,
übersetzt.
Da wird Windows nicht.
deaktiviert also 14 oktober 2025 gut es ist noch eineinhalb naja nicht ganz so
das ist das ist noch ganze ecke über einem jahr hin und ich ganz ehrlich ich
habe ich habe es ja auch schon ein paar mal gesagt hat was ja schon öfters mal
von ich glaube nicht dass microsoft das so eiskalt handhaben wird wenn es sich
bewahrheitet wenn es sich bewahrheitet dass die verbreitung von windows 11
immer noch so stockend vorangeht ich habe mir jetzt die letzte zeit
keine statistik immer angeguckt aber das letzte mal als ich geguckt habe hatte
glaube ich wenn aus elf 13 prozent oder sowas mpc progress rate
schön also das war glaube ich bei 15 prozent oder so was
ja
Ist nicht der Marktanteil von Windows 11 gesungen?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab letztens
irgend so, ich hab dazu mal ein Video gemacht.
So, und
laut Statistik ein Flop.
So, und da hab ich hier
so ne, so ne, da gab's ja, gibt's ja mehrere,
gibt's ja wieder zig Statistiken.
So, das Video ist aber zwei Jahre alt.
Ja, und
ich hab natürlich auch
meine Quellen nicht ins Video geschrieben, dass ich
jetzt nachgucken könnte.
So wie
sich das gehört, ja.
Ähm, so.
Und da war Windows 11,
ja genau, da gab's mehrere
Sachen.
So, und da war Windows 11 bei,
keine Ahnung, was
ist denn das hier für ne Seite?
Desktop Windows Market
Share, gucken wir mal.
Und schon wieder, ne, ich hab keine Videos angeguckt.
Hier, das da, das da, das ist es, glaub ich.
So, also Desktop Operation
System Market Share.
Windows, ja.
Das ist mir
auch klar.
Ja, Windows Version
Market Share, hier.
Windows 10, ganz
ehrlich, Microsoft wird im
Leben nicht
den Support einstellen für Windows 10,
also harter Cut nächstes Jahr im Oktober,
wenn das noch über 50%
liegt. Selbst wenn das
über 20% liegt, kann ich mir das nicht
vorstellen. Das ist einfach nur ein bisschen
Säbeln rasseln von Microsoft, so nach dem Motto
seht her, Windows 11 hat keiner Bock drauf,
jetzt upgrade, das wird nicht passieren.
Ich sag euch auch warum.
Microsoft hat die letzten Jahre über sehr viel
dafür getan, sowohl
Image-technisch
als auch
Betriebssystem-seitig,
dass Windows als halbwegs sicher
wieder wahrgenommen wird. Das war früher überhaupt
nicht der Fall. Denkt mal zurück an
Windows 98 Zeiten.
Wie hieß dieses Ding damals noch
mit, ich weiß nicht mehr,
wie das hieß, wenn du damals ein Windows
98 PC
ans Internet gehängt hast,
da waren NetBios,
BOI, Gedöns,
Port 445 und so, war alles offen
und es hat, glaube ich, damals
hat es jemand mal getestet,
irgendwie 28 Sekunden gedauert,
bis
in Windows, also 28 Sekunden
am Internet, für eine Windows 98
Kiste damals, bis das Ding infiziert
war. Moin.
Wisst ihr noch, wie dieses Ding hieß?
Windows 98
Security 445 Internet.
Wie hieß denn dieses Ding?
Das war super, super bekannt.
Blaster?
War das Blaster?
Ich glaube, das war Blaster.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor, der Name.
Ne. Aber ist ähnlich.
Ja, doch.
Ja, genau, genau, genau, genau.
Oder war das,
sorry, ich verwechsel das mit Windows XP.
Das habe ich jetzt mit Windows XP
verwechselt hier. Aber das kannst du vergessen.
So, und der Grund,
damals war halt, Microsoft hatte ein bisschen drauf
geschissen.
Ja, sie waren das
verbreitetste Betriebssystem und
waren deswegen natürlich auch den meisten Angriffen
ausgesetzt, aber Microsoft hat es ein bisschen verschissen.
Die haben enorm viel gemacht.
Nach 10 Minuten. Das war
viel schneller. 10 Minuten ist ja
gar nichts.
Das waren Sekunden.
Ja, heute. Heute.
Heute, ganz ehrlich.
Wer scannt heute noch nach Windows XP
Rechnern, um die zu infizieren?
Es gibt sicherlich noch genug, aber weil,
das waren Sekunden damals.
Ich bin ja im Internet. Windows XP ungepatcht.
So, und Microsoft hat da
sehr viel dafür getan.
Auch Security-technisch.
Es ist übrigens eines der Gründe,
warum Windows, was kam nach
XP? Vista.
Warum Windows Vista so abgekackt
ist, war, weil Windows Vista
eigentlich
der Fall, also der nicht
gewollte Zwischenschritt war.
Was wissen wir? Was Vista?
Ich bring's grad durch nach Vista, gell?
Ja.
Windows Vista hat nämlich Windows XP SP2
rausgebracht damals.
Als Update, was
ein riesen
Umbruch war, wie Windows unter der Haube
funktioniert hat, gerade was Security-Features
anging. Und das war denen so
wichtig,
dass sie das als Windows XP SP2
rausgebracht haben und nicht
als neues Windows. Deswegen
wurde Windows Vista so schnell
wie es geht irgendwie rausgeschissen,
damit man seinen Enterprise Security
Release-Zyklus einhalten konnte.
Ja, also Microsoft hat enorm
viel dafür getan die letzten Jahre, sowohl
Marketing-technisch, Image-mäßig, als
auch Security-mäßig in ihrem Betriebssystem,
dass es wieder als halbwegs sicher wahrgenommen
wird. Ich mein, Microsoft kann auch nix
dafür, wenn die Rentner
dieser Welt jede Toolbar
installieren müssen oder jeden Mist
anklicken müssen. Irgendwann ist auch mal gut,
aber im Vergleich zu früher
ist Windows heute
deutlich stabiler und deutlich sicherer
und problemloser zu benutzen.
Ah, problemloser zu benutzen,
würd ich nicht sagen. Das nehm ich zurück, aber
die anderen zwei Sachen stimmen.
Und das wird sich Microsoft
garantiert, und da wette ich mit euch,
ähm,
um nix, aber ich wette
mit euch,
um ein YouTube-Video. Ich würd's mal wieder
eins machen. Könnt ihr dann
Ende 2025 einlösen.
Deswegen wird's Microsoft nicht riskieren,
hier die Support einzustellen und das
wieder wegzuschmeißen. Weil stellt euch mal vor,
Microsoft
würde tatsächlich
in knapp über nem Jahr,
gut über nem Jahr,
den Support für Windows 10 droppen.
Dann wären wir vielleicht, keine Ahnung,
bei 55% oder so.
Überlegt euch mal, 55%
der Rechner,
der Desktop-Rechner, bekommen auf einen Schlag
keine Updates mehr. Es kommen Sicherheitslücken
raus, easy auszunutzen,
und in zwei, drei Monaten
danach, oder später, sagen wir mal ein halbes
Jahr, es brauchen schon mal richtig ordentlich
fette, große Sicherheitslücken.
Ja, so Dinger mit, ich hab das Falsche
angeklickt und so. Am besten brauchst du irgendeinen
Drive-By, wenn du nur auf die falsche
Webseite gehst oder so. Das dauert ein bisschen,
bis da was richtig Fettes bei rauskommt, ja.
Und dann sind,
da sind 50% der
PCs auf, der Desktop-PCs auf der
Welt, oder der Windows-Desktop-PCs auf der
Welt am Arsch. Was meint ihr, was das
mit dem Ruf von Microsoft macht?
Scheiß drauf, dass die gesagt haben, wir stellen
Windows 10 Support ein.
Meint ihr, das interessiert
den Opa, die Oma,
wer auch immer, die weltweite
Technik-Loops, das ist denen doch vollkommen
egal, die hören bloß noch Windows 10, ja.
Kann sich noch einer
erinnern, wie das bei Windows 7 Support-Ende war?
Also bei Windows XP und Windows 7,
das wurde so weit in die Zukunft
verschoben alles, bis das
halbwegs
niedrig war, der Support.
Also mir kann niemand erzählen, dass Microsoft
den Support einstellt,
bei einem Betriebssystem,
wo die Verbreitung
über 50% liegt.
Und selbst, wenn wir nächstes Jahr
bei 40% sind, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Die haben da so hart dran gearbeitet,
die letzten Jahre, über gerade auch wieder ihren Ruf
halbwegs herzustellen, dass man Windows
mehr oder weniger sicher verwenden kann,
das kannst du vergessen. Genau.
10% ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich
mir das durchaus vorstellen kann.
Und...
Ja, also wie gesagt,
daran glaube ich nicht. Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass es verschiedene Sachen gibt.
Microsoft wird wahrscheinlich,
so, nennen wir es mal gesichtswahrend,
sagen, Support wird eingestellt,
wird aber gleichzeitig ein
neues Support-Programm ankündigen oder sowas.
Also quasi, es gibt dann
offizieller Support-Ende,
aber jetzt gibt es
irgendwas, was anders heißt.
Äh, Maintenance...
Support, was auch immer.
Da kreieren sie, das kann Microsoft Marketing
natürlich, ja, die kreieren dann
irgendein zusätzliches Ding und dann ist
das wieder so.
Ja, Moment, das ist die Paid-Sache.
Es geht ja hier um normale Leute,
die das daheim verwenden, die keinen
LTS Paid, sonst war es Business Edition,
haben. Wie gesagt,
das wird nicht passieren.
Das
würde mich extrem
wundern, wenn das passiert.
So. Und
deswegen, ich werde auch upgraden,
also hier habe ich ja schon Windows 11, aber auf einem anderen
PC, ich werde auch upgraden, aber
trotzdem, fuckt mich ab, wenn ich
mich einlogge auf meinem Windows 10,
PC. Und so ein Ding hier wird
im Fullscreen angezeigt.
Da kriegst du es erst mal mit der Angst zu tun, da sagst du, fuck, dein Rechner
ist im Arsch. Der Twitch-Chat
ist bei mir auf meinem
Vorschau-Rechner.
Und dann stellst du fest, ach nee,
ist bloß nicht schlecht. Das war sogar richtig,
richtig, das war so
noch ein Bild mit einer richtig
miesen Auflösung, sodass man Kompressions-
Artefakte gesehen hat. Fullscreen-Ads.
Also das muss nicht
sein. Oh, eine F-Programmer.
Vielleicht haben wir das auf der
Arbeit. Deswegen haben wir auch noch
keine Windows, kein Windows Clipboard.
Schon das Copilot Plus Video
angeschaut. Ich gucke sehr
gerne Fireship-Videos, aber
der AI-Content
langweilt mich zunehmend.
Ja. Aber wie gesagt, aktuell reden wir ja von
60, 60% plus, das wird nicht passieren.
Vista hat tatsächlich ein paar
coole Sachen gebracht, ja. Gerade wie Windows
ein Fenster rendert und alles, das ist
also mit DWM heißt das, glaube ich,
DMD. Ja, dieses
Composite-Rendering und so, was Windows auch macht.
Das ist halt Vista. Also vieles, was
unter der Haube heute normal ist, kam
tatsächlich mit Vista.
Nur, dass Vista
nicht gut angekommen ist.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, das schlechteste Windows, was ich je erlebt
habe, vom Faktor, wie
gut es bei den Leuten ankommt, war tatsächlich
Windows 8.
Fällt euch irgendwas anderes ein, was ähnlich
schlecht... Ups, will mein QM nicht ausschalten.
Was ähnlich schlecht ist wie Windows 8?
Selbst
ME nicht. Selbst ME
haben die Leute verwendet und haben gesagt,
ja, das ist halt
ein Windows 98 mit ein bisschen anderen
Icons und so und gebraucht hätte es
keiner. Aber Windows
8,
das wurde ja regelrecht
das wurde uninstalled
im Endeffekt. Wenn der Rechner
mit Windows 8 kam, die haben das uninstalled.
Das ist bei Windows ME
nicht passiert. Ja, 8.1 hat es dann
wieder ein bisschen besser gemacht.
Windows 3.1 muss doch der Wahnsinn gewesen sein.
Naja, das liegt nicht daran,
dass das der Wahnsinn ist oder gewesen
ist.
Windows 3.11 oder
Windows 3.1 oder was auch immer die Bahn genau verwendet,
das war zur
damaligen Zeit, als diese
Anzeigen-Terminals entwickelt wurden,
halt anscheinend das Ding schlechthin.
Man hat halt darauf aufgesetzt
und
das Ding... Warum sollte
man das ändern? Ich hab da
volles Verständnis für die Bahn.
Warum sollte man das ändern? Das ist ein
in sich geschlossenes System,
ohne Internet-Anbindung
oder sonst was.
Das läuft
halt. Warum solltest du
alles austauschen?
Heutzutage, ganz
ehrlich, heutzutage würde Linux unter sowas
laufen. Aber sicherlich
auch kein top aktuelles.
Du hast teilweise noch irgendwelches
Embedded-Gedöns mit Kernel 2.4
oder 2.6,
wenn es ein bisschen moderner ist.
Ich meine, der Kernel wurde ja glaube ich damals
zu irgendeinem Linux-Geburtstag
quasi, wurde Version 3
released, nach 2.6,
keine Ahnung, 35, 36
oder so, gab's dann
gab's dann 3, nee, oder
4, oder ach, ich weiß
gar nicht, wo wir sind. Wir sind jetzt bei 5, gell?
Das hat ja immer bei Linux keinen
ne, äh, bei 6...
Das hat ja bei Linux immer keinen tieferen Sinn.
Heute, heute wird
da garantiert Linux drauflaufen.
Auf solchen Dingern.
Es gibt rmv-Terminals,
da,
es hat leider nie
einer ein Bild von gemacht,
auf den Kartenautomaten vom rmv,
das ist hier dieses, bei mir hier
in der Ecke,
der Rhein-Main-Verkehrsverbund,
die laufen auf Raspberry Pi
Basis. Hat das vielleicht mal
einer auf Reddit oder so gepostet?
Hier, da, die neuen rmv-Ticketautomaten
laufen auf Raspberry Pis.
Nice, genau, ja.
Das sieht man manchmal.
Ist kein Witz, hab ich selbst schon gesehen.
Also es ist kein Photoshop oder so.
Mit eigenen Augen schon erblickt.
Die laufen auf Raspberry Pi Basis
und ernsthaft, das ist auch sehr sinnvoll.
Der Vorteil liegt doch auf der Hand.
Also erstens ist es Linux,
da musst du dir um Stabilität schon mal
keine Gedanken machen. Du kannst das super
remote administrieren, du kannst das
super auch für embedded Sachen
verwenden und
das Beste ist halt,
wenn du es auf dem Raspberry Pi aufsetzt,
schnell ist das, ja, schnell
genug ist das Ding, aber wenn du es auf dem
Raspberry Pi aufsetzt, du hast
keinerlei Hardware-Nachschubprobleme.
Okay, hat man sich damals gedacht,
die wussten ja nicht,
die wussten ja nicht, wie es 2024
aussieht mit Raspberry Pis,
aber du hast auf jeden Fall
eine bessere
Verfügbarkeit
von Ersatzteilen, als
bei irgendeinem speziell angefertigten
Custom Board nur für diesen
Automat, was anscheinend noch gebundelt wird
vom Hersteller. Also der Gedanke dahinter,
da ein Raspberry Pi reinzustecken,
mit irgendwie,
wahrscheinlich ist die Oberfläche letztendlich auch nur
ein Chrome oder irgendein Elektronen-Gedöns,
was im Fullscreen läuft,
ist nicht schlecht.
Ich vermute, da steckt ein Raspberry Pi Compute
Model oder wie das heißt drinnen, kein normaler
Raspberry Pi, man weiß nicht.
Also heute würde da auch garantiert
bei der Bahn, wo Windows 3.11 draufläuft,
würde heute garantiert Linux drauflaufen.
Ja, aber du musst wahrscheinlich mehr
bezahlen, oder?
Linux auf den Innenanzeigen der ICE-Flotte der DB.
Oh.
Ja, das macht auch komplett
Sinn.
WSL, WSL ist auch schon ein paar Jahre alt.
Ja, wundert mich nicht.
Klar geht das.
Wenn du was in der Programmiersprache entwickelst,
die du nach ARM
Architektur compilen kannst,
dann läuft das und
mir fällt nichts ein, was
ich heutzutage nicht auch für ARM-CPUs
übersetzen ließe.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass
historisch bedingt vielleicht die Package-Auswahl,
wenn du mal einen Debian
vergleichst, den x86-Debian
mit einem ARM-Debian
vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner ist,
aber für eigenentwickelten
Kram, das ist übrigens
ein gutes Stichwort.
Wie easy
ist es eigentlich mit Go,
ein Go-Programm,
Cross zu Compilen von x86
auf einem x86
für ARM?
Das sollte sehr easy sein.
Du musst aber wahrscheinlich nur noch Go-Arch
angeben.
Das wollte ich nämlich mal ausprobieren,
denn
SSH
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch,
es sind so viele Sachen
gleichzeitig.
Also ja, das geht.
Du kannst sogar .NET-Programme
.NET-Programme, also Microsoft
.NET
nicht .NET Framework
4.8, sondern
ich rede von .NET, was seit Version
5 von
.NET Core umbenannt wurde in .NET.
Das heißt,
.NET 5 ist kein Nachfolger von
.NET Framework 4.8, aber ich will euch nicht
mit Microsoft-Namensgebung langweilen.
Sogar Microsoft .NET
Programme laufen mittlerweile ohne Probleme
unter ARM.
Allerdings nur
nur
ARM V7.
Mindestens,
glaube ich.
Die erste Raspberry Pi
Zero Version, das war noch
ARM V6, glaube ich.
Da läuft das
nicht drauf.
Also ich weiß nicht, was
du machst, aber bei mir heißen die .NET-Programme
unter linuxnicht.exe
SAP ausgelaufen.
Z.
Hat die Abo-Falle nicht funktioniert.
Denkst du, X11 wird bald
unsupported sein? Kommt darauf an,
von was?
Generell glaube ich nicht,
dass wir X11
irgendwann mal in nächster Zeit rausfliegen sehen
aus großen Distributionen.
Das Problem ist ja, dass Wayland beispielsweise
in der VM auch immer noch gescheit funktioniert.
Ich denke auch, X11 wird uns
sehr, sehr lange noch halten bleiben.
Wer ist das?
Ja, aber nicht auf den normalen Arduinos.
Das muss ein spezieller Arduino
sein.
Auf den normalen, ich habe vergessen,
welche CPUs die Arduinos haben.
Da läuft kein Linux drauf.
Und die Arduinos sind in der Regel nicht
dafür bekannt, dass sie sonderlich schnell
sind. Und wenn da ein Betriebssystem mit Linux
drauf läuft, glaube ich nicht, dass es
im Raspberry Pi Ersatz auch nur annähernd ist.
Nicht mal für den Zero.
Aber ich weiß es nicht. Welcher ist das denn?
Vielleicht
bestimmt hatte ich das Problem auch
schon mal und habe mich dann geärgert, wo es hin ist.
Ich habe manchmal das Problem, wenn ich Shorts
geguckt habe, die in der History zu finden.
Die stehen manchmal einfach nicht drinnen.
Ah, der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Joho, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay,
SQL Injection hat
funktioniert.
Doch, doch, das geht.
Man kann Windows 11 noch installieren.
Oh, mein Auge!
Was ist da drinnen?
Das stimmt, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal probiert.
Und ich habe langsam keinen Bock mehr.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich WLAN probiere, funktioniert irgendwas nicht.
Ich brauche nur neun Stunden zum booten.
Das ist ja nichts.
Machst du morgens an und
pünktlich, wenn du heimkommst?
Geht's.
Ist auch nice.
Wie schnell erscheint dann da irgendwas, wenn du was eintippst?
Also wie lange dauert ein
SSH-Login danach, falls da SSH überhaupt
drauf läuft?
Ein SSH-Login ist vielleicht nicht so krass
wie booten, aber eine Stunde wird es schon dauern,
oder?
Das Ding kann überhaupt keine SSH-Keys erstellen.
Das SSH-Key erstellen dauert
auf dem Ding wahrscheinlich drei Jahre.
Ja,
warum ich frage,
warum ich so blöd gefragt habe,
kann man das nicht für ARM übersetzen?
Ich habe doch ein
DVB-C-Receiver.
SSH
ich glaube 129?
Da ist er!
Ich habe einen DVB-C-Receiver,
auf den ich per SSH kann.
Wer kennt's nicht?
Habt ihr auch einen DVB-C-Receiver,
wo man sich per SSH drauf einloggen kann?
Wie geht's deinem Staubsauger?
Den verwende ich nicht mehr.
Der ist aus, den verwende ich nicht mehr.
Ja.
Den gibt's.
Also ich kann mich hier per SSH einloggen
auf meinem
TV-Receiver drüben.
Man kann auch H-Top oder so
äh
ja
Guck mal hier.
H-Top
H-Top auf meinem
DVB-C-Receiver.
Ist es nicht nice?
Ja.
Und wer sich da vielleicht wundert, warum da TV-Header
entläuft,
das benutze ich zum Streamen vom Fernsehprogramm.
Das Ding hat insgesamt 8 Tuner
und da ist ein TV-Header
drauf. Das Ding wird standardmäßig
nicht so ausgeliefert, ja?
Musstest du da alle Packages
bauen? Nein, da ist OpenATV
drauf, als Firmware.
Ja.
Und da ist das meiste schon dabei.
Beziehungsweise du kannst
mit Package oder so
oder OOPK
List glaub ich ist es.
Kannst die Packages anzeigen lassen,
die du da installieren kannst.
Und
naja
zumindest da läuft ein TV-Header drauf.
DVB-Server
ist glaub ich was, was mit ausgeliefert wird.
Das ist glaub ich nix von mir.
Aber das ist hier.
Das hab ich nachher installiert.
Also TV-Header
und Mini-SAT.
Mini-SAT kümmert sich quasi
um das Reden mit
den 8
DVB-C Receivern
und TV-Header
greift dann auf Mini-SAT zu, um
das TV-Programm davon abzugreifen.
Was für einer ist das?
Das ist ein, genau so einer.
Dieses Teil.
By the way, ich kann nicht empfehlen,
das Ding zu verwenden, wenn man einen
TV-Receiver haben will, den man
an den Fernseher anschließt.
Da kann ich nicht dafür empfehlen.
Ich finde die Oberfläche absolut grausam
und das was vorinstalliert ist
noch grausamer.
Wofür das Ding gut ist, ist
ein netzwerkfähiges
Linux-Gerät zu haben
mit 8 DVB-C Empfängern, von dem aus
man Fernsehprogramm streamen kann.
Nicht irgendwie,
um es an den Fernseher direkt
anzuschließen. Dafür fand ich das
richtig grausam mies.
Richtig nervig.
Ich habe Shield TV drüben
im Wohnzimmer am Fernseher
und
da drauf Kodi mit dem TV-Headern-Plugin
um darauf zu streamen.
Aber ich gucke eh so gut wie nie Fernsehen.
So, und
was mir aufgefallen ist,
das Ding hat ja eine AMV7-CPU.
Und jetzt habe ich was gefunden
auf Github heute.
TVHellGo.
Der hat sowas gebaut, was ich auch schon mal
gebaut habe. Aber umso weniger
Software ich mich selbst drum kümmern muss, umso besser.
Der hat ein Web-Interface
gebaut für TV-Headern.
Wo man beispielsweise
vom Smartphone Fernsehaufnahmen
programmieren kann und sowas. Wo man nicht hoch zum Fernsehen
gehen muss oder zu irgendeinem
Gerät mit Kodi drauf oder
TV-Headern-Client und so drauf.
Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
So ein Web-Interface.
Da kann meine Mutter Rosamunde Pilcher
und so gedönst halt direkt vom Handy aus
programmieren. Das ist aber ein
Programm. Und
das
gibt es nicht vorkompiliert für
es gibt einen Docker-Container, da bringt mir aber nix.
Das gibt es nicht fix und
fertig für ARM.
Deswegen wollte ich mal gucken.
Der Chat scheint
sich da ja auszukennen.
EPG Champ Extended Edition.
Ich habe auch mal sowas gebaut.
Nein, nein, nein. Der EPG Champ.
Guck mal. Github.
Github. Github.
EPG Champ.
Ich habe auch mal sowas gebaut.
So ein Web-Interface für das Ding.
Aber
das funktioniert,
aber hat so seine Probleme. Das heißt, wenn es was ist,
worum ich mich nicht drum kümmern muss,
umso besser.
Ist der Docker-Container nicht auch für ARM gebaut?
Da kann man sich das Binary rauskopieren.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich probiere es mal selbst zu kompilieren.
Wie funzt das?
Ja.
Go Build.
Warte mal.
Go Build ARM V7.
Irgendwas mit Go Arch.
Habe ich das nicht noch hier?
Go Arch?
Ah ja, guck mal. Hier habe ich schon noch was.
Go OS Linux.
Das ist was anderes.
Aber hier, das können wir schon mal finden.
Das ist hier
eine Library zu bauen.
So, also das
uns ja so. Schau mal.
Hier habe ich irgendwie wieder Go Arch
oder sowas, gell?
Kann man eben da sagen.
Go Arch.
Äh.
Was sagt man?
Go Arch gleich ARM
und dann was?
Go ARM V7.
So.
Und jetzt geht das
einfach. Schauen wir mal.
Erst mal explodiert
alles hier.
Das sollte sich hier drauf nicht ausführen
lassen. Ja, richtig.
Richtig.
Es ist ein 32
Bit Executable für
ARM.
Das hört sich schon mal gut an.
SCPen wir mal das rüber.
Es geht.
Easy.
Also es gibt ja viele Sachen, die ich an Go
kacke finde. Die mich nerven,
wenn ich Go verwende. Aber
die Fähigkeit Standalone
Binaries raus zu
kacken
ist sehr
based bei Go.
Muss man sagen.
Also das ist schon nice.
Was mir halt an Go nicht gefällt
sind einige syntaktische
Entscheidungen der Sprache
und diesen
Wie nennen wir das denn mal?
Sinnlosen Hang zum
Minimalismus.
Wobei ich gar nicht behaupten
würde, dass Go, also
das wird ja immer unter dem
Deckmantel von Go muss minimalistisch
und einfach bleiben gemacht.
Aber Go ist an vielen Ecken auch
nicht einfach und minimalistisch.
Zum Beispiel
also eine Sache,
die mir in Go überhaupt nicht gefällt ist
diese leidige Geschichte
mit, es gibt kein
Filter.
Sondern es gibt nur
For Loop in For Loop in For Loop.
Das ist das Ding,
wo ich immer sage, muss das wirklich sein?
Sogar Javascript
hat seit Jahren einen Punktfilter.
Mittlerweile mit Generics, die übrigens auch
sehr weirdchamp gelöst sind
in Go, ist es
mit Zusatzlibraries ein bisschen besser geworden.
Wobei ich da noch keine richtig gute gefunden habe bis jetzt.
E-Names habe ich
gar nicht im Kopf. Und auch wenn
man dann teilweise so Sachen machen muss wie
Was war
das letztens?
Wo du die Sachen immer nicht findest und dann sind die in
Strings Punkt
Namespace drinne.
Ja, es gibt ein paar Sachen.
Ich müsste mir auch mal eine Datei machen, Go suckt
und alles was mich an Go nervt mal aufschreiben.
Die Liste wird natürlich
bei weitem nicht so lang
wie meine Anti-C++
Liste. Ich könnte übrigens auch
zu C-Sharp, ja, wir wissen ja, dass ich
C-Sharp Fanboy bin, auch zu C-Sharp
eine relativ lange Liste machen.
Die mir Sachen, die mir nicht
gefallen. Beispielsweise
den Hang dazu,
dass Microsoft Sachen in die Sprache
einbaut, die nur
sie brauchen und sonst
irgendwie keiner checkt, warum die da sind.
Blickt irgendjemand noch durch
mittlerweile in C-Sharp zwischen dieser ganzen
Geschichte von
struct
ref struct
struct record
ref class
das ist ja Default ohne ref
ref
refs record
struct, was auch immer es da
alles gibt.
Ja, man kann nachgucken,
aber intuitiv ist es
nicht. Und das Problem ist, dass sich sogar
manche Sachen trotz gleicher Syntax anders
verhalten. Also ist auch nicht alles schön.
Wer das benutzt, ich benutze das gerne.
Und ein nicht
unerheblicher Teil der
weit verbreiteten Software ist
auch in C-Sharp programmiert.
Es ist, oder eine Sache,
wo man sich drüber streiten kann, sind Default
Interfaces. Das geht noch in Ordnung, finde ich.
Aber Microsoft hat so viele
Sachen reingebaut, auch um ihre Office
Libraries
ein bisschen mehr frei von Overloads
zu machen. Man muss sich nur die letzten
C-Sharp
Features Overview angucken
bei Version.
Da findet man vieles,
da findet man vieles, was Microsoft
einbaut. Ja,
Primary Constructors ist ein Ding. Ich persönlich
mag Primary Constructors nicht.
Collection Expressions
ist auch nice, ist auch
auch okay.
Ref Read Only Parameter
ist natürlich auch wieder so ein Ding, was nur Microsoft
braucht. Alias ein
Type. Ja, dass das Ganze noch
unleserlicher wird, wobei das durchaus
wahrscheinlich seine Berechtigung haben kann.
Okay, okay, okay.
Auto Default Structs, da weiß ich
ja schon gar nicht mehr, was das ist.
Achso, okay.
Ref Fields and Ref
Scoped Variables.
Whatever. Ja, da muss man
sich mal in Ruhe angucken.
Aber, es gibt ein neues Feature.
Was, der Discord Link funktioniert
nicht mehr, wirklich nicht.
Mod Check, wenn der abgelaufen ist,
wäre sehr nice, wenn ihr den erneuern könntet.
Es kommt übrigens in der nächsten
C-Sharp Version ein
mega geiles Feature.
Da freue ich mich schon richtig drüber.
Und zwar ein Feature, was
mal vor Jahren schon angekündigt
war unter Extend
Everything. Ich kann mich noch
an den, genau,
2016 hier gucken.
Wurde das mal angekündigt.
Ich kann mich noch an einen Talk,
einen Konferenztalk erinnern von
Oh, ich spreche den
wahrscheinlich komplett falsch aus.
Mads Torgeson
oder so heißt der, Oberst C-Sharp-Dude.
Und da war
die Idee, dass man
Extension Methods
erweitert. Also, dass es nicht nur
Extension Methods gibt,
sondern, dass es jetzt
Extension Properties gibt,
Extension Static Sachen und solche Geschichten.
Und
sie haben es geschafft, also
so wie es hier beschrieben war, wollten sie nicht.
Aber sie haben es jetzt geschafft,
so ein ähnliches
Feature für C-Sharp 3er
Sneak Chops, das Video,
der hat ein gutes Video dazu gemacht.
So. Und
das ist richtig,
richtig nice. Da kann man jetzt
nämlich, äh,
okay, gibt es aber nicht.
Da kann man jetzt nämlich wirklich das
meiste, was es gibt.
Warum machen die einfach nicht ein Beispiel dabei,
dabei, man, ja. Genau.
Man kann jetzt hier sagen,
äh, das ist aber nix, nix, äh.
Das ist ein
schlechtes Beispiel, weil das konnte man vorher schon machen.
Das ist ja so ziemlich das schlechteste
Beispiel ever.
Das ging vorher auch schon.
Der hätte das mit einem Property
machen müssen. Man kann jetzt eine Klasse
Extenden, die nicht im eigenen Source Code ist,
beispielsweise
mit neuen Static Methoden,
und das sieht dann so aus hier, ja.
Da würde man reinschreiben, public static,
da gibt es das Ding als neue Static Methode.
Man kann ein Property reinschreiben,
also man kann quasi auch Klassen,
die einem nicht gehören,
die auch in der Standard Library drin sind,
zum Beispiel, oder von irgendeiner Library auf GitHub,
kann man Extenden mit Sachen, die man
braucht.
Das eliminiert ganz viele Helper
Punkt irgendwas Geschichten.
Oder,
ja, irgendwie die,
den x-ten Rapper für irgendwas.
Weil man das einfach direkt an die Klasse
attachen kann. Das ist richtig geil.
Aus meiner Sicht wäre dieses Feature, also
generell Extension Methods, wir wollen jetzt mal nicht übertreiben,
aus meiner Sicht
eines nicht sonderlich
high IQ
geskillten C++
Programmierers,
wäre aus meiner Sicht
Extension Methods
eines der besten
Features, was das C++
Gremium für diese Sprache machen könnte.
Aber das C++ Gremium will ja, glaube ich,
nichts Gutes für C++ machen,
deswegen kommt die letzten Jahre zu 90%
irgendein Schrott bei rum.
Extension Methods wären für C++
extrem geil, weil
die C++ Standard Library ist
so ein inkonsistenter Schrotthaufen,
mit Extension Methods
könntest du das halbwegs
usable machen. Du könntest zum Beispiel
jetzt, ja,
Gott bewahre,
man könnte dann in C++
vielleicht sowas sagen wie,
ja, keine Ahnung, Vector of Int,
Punkt
Filter,
das wäre eine gute
hier B,
und dann müsste da B Punkt Filter,
das könnte man tatsächlich dann wirklich in C++
machen mit Extension Methods, stellt euch das mal
vor, dann müsste man nicht
mehr machen, Moment,
Exempel, also allein
schon, wenn ich so einen Artikel sehe,
12 different ways
to filter containers,
sogar JavaScript
hat nicht 12
verschiedene Wege,
also Wege, die jemand benutzen würde,
um einen Container zu filtern.
Also einmal von der Syntax
außen vor, ok,
ja, das kann man machen, so, Moment,
ey, das ist schon
immerhin die neue Loop-Variante,
das ist übrigens, um jetzt mal
ein bisschen gegen Go zu flamen,
das ist übrigens The Go Way,
eine Liste zu filtern.
In Go macht man das
genauso,
genauso wie hier,
und das ist das, was ich meine,
dieser Hang
zum Fake-Minimalismus
in Go nervt mich an vielen Stellen.
Natürlich, jeder
versteht, was hier passiert, oder?
Oh, das ist so gut lesbar!
Also, das ist ja
easy!
Die Sprache, die hört nie auf, mich abzufangen.
Gut, das ist jetzt die Generic-Variante,
ja?
In Go wäre das lesbarer,
das ist richtig.
Ja, ja, das ist zum Beispiel
eines der
modernen Wege,
das in Go
zu machen.
Das
checkt
wieder mal keiner, ey.
Erase If,
Copy If,
ok, sagen wir mal hier,
damit kann man leben, oder?
Copy If, Begin.
So, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
C++ hätte sowas wie
Extension Methods.
Dann müsste man nicht sagen,
Standard, Copy If, Begin, End,
bla, blub, Back Inserter,
whatever,
Dings, P, was ist P? Ah, ah, ok,
die Funktion zum Filtern, ok, alles klar.
So, und dann könnte man
nämlich, dann könnte man nämlich,
wenn man das hier beispielsweise in Extension
Method für, sagen wir, einen Int Vector
packen könnte, dann könnte man nämlich einfach sagen,
Int Vector,
ja, oder Int,
wie auch immer, wie auch immer, die Variable
Punkt,
meinetwegen sogar Copy If, wenn es sein müsste.
So, und dann braucht man diese hässliche
Syntax von C++
und sagt dann hier,
x größer 2, so.
Das wäre doch
um Längen besser lesbar
als dieser Schrott.
Und eine For Loop lässt sich halt viel
besser erweitern. Was willst du denn an der
Filter For Loop großartig erweitern?
Wenn ich ein
Array filtern will auf alle Elemente
größer als 2,
dann mache ich, dann mache ich sowas hier.
Genau sowas hier.
Und ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das
nicht erweitern könnte. Ich könnte hier
davor aber schreiben, ich könnte auch hier schreiben, Keckel
und sonst was, ja.
Es spricht auch nichts dagegen, danach
nochmal eine Schleife drüber zu machen oder sowas.
Wenn man mit den Elementen, die man gefiltert
hat, was machen will.
Und wenn es wirklich, wenn es ein Performance Problem ist,
dann kann ich immer noch sagen, ok,
ich mache eine Schleife, da drin ein If
und nur das wird rausgefiltert,
falls das irgendwie dann
das paar Zyklen,
paar CPU-Zyklen spart.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich finde sowas hier
um Längen besser lesbar
als den Go-Weg und den
StarC++-Weg auch. Ich meine,
guck mal, was ist schöner, Leute?
Da stehst du, City-Boy,
Moin! Dein Name kennt
ich noch. Alter, du bist
schon, bist du noch da? Du bist ja schon
richtig lange dabei.
Kann das sein,
das müssen wir mal jetzt hier kurz,
wir unterbrechen das normale Programm für eine wichtige
Durchsage, Leute.
Kann das sein,
dass der City-Boy
sogar mal ein Audiokommentar
geschickt hat,
an eure
Fragen oder sowas,
Video,
dazu? Vor 12 Jahren?
Bist du da in einem dieser Videos
drinne? Dein Name kommt mir nämlich
bekannt vor. Ich bilde
mir ein, wir haben City-Boy ausgesprochen
in dem Video.
Hast du damals irgendwas eingeschickt dazu?
Ich suche jetzt mal
danach.
Pass mal auf.
Moment.
Da bist du nur in den Kommentaren, glaube ich.
Ach, wir haben Garden Warfare mit dem Friseur
gespielt. Vielleicht kenne ich dich dann. Dein Name kommt
auf jeden Fall bekannt vor. Hast du mal Lust
xDefine auszuprobieren? Ja.
Habe ich.
Wir haben damals
ein 40.000-Abo-Special gemacht, wo man
Kommentare einschicken konnte und die haben wir dann
abgespielt. Damals
noch mit irgendeinem ganz merkwürdigen Skype-Audiorekorder
aufgenommen und sowas.
Die haben wir abgespielt und dann haben wir was zugesagt.
Ja.
Ja, habe ich vor auszuprobieren.
Eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen abschreckt
ist,
das erste, was ich gehört habe ist,
dass sie gesagt haben, also eines der ersten Sachen,
die ich von dem Spiel gehört habe ist, dass sie gesagt
haben, sie haben kein Skill-Based Matchmaking
und eines der ersten Sachen, die ich jetzt
gelesen habe, zu Release oder zu... Ist das überhaupt
schon echt, dass Release jetzt ist?
Doch, sie haben Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Kennst du noch den Brief
von... Was?
Sag... Wie?
Brief jetzt?
Welcher Brief?
Adventskalender?
Ah. Nee.
Okay. Moment. Die Welcome
Playlist hat SBMM.
Ist das, um die Leute direkt wieder
abzuschrecken von dem Game? Oder, dass
die Noobs überhaupt mal irgendwas
killen? Weißt du noch, als du dich
in der Suppe gespiegelt hast? Klar weiß ich das noch.
Natürlich.
Max FPS
Suppe.
Eindeutig spiegel ich mich.
Eindeutig spiegel ich mich in der
Suppe.
Leaked.
Haha.
Wieso?
Hahaha.
Alles klar.
Max FPS Suppe.
Hahaha.
Was?
Warum steht da
Max FPS drinnen?
Kostenlose
Sexfilme. Tochter verführt ihren
Stiefvater. Max FPS
Gesicht.
Haha.
Hey.
Jeder hat so seins, worauf
er steht. Ja.
Hey Leute, mal zurück zum Thema.
Ich wollte euch eigentlich was fragen.
Ist vollkommen egal, was hier drinnen steht.
Ignoriert mal, was hier steht, okay?
Du bekommst das Ergebnis
nicht. Vielleicht
möchte mir Google irgendwas sagen.
So.
Hattest du nicht eine Bekannte, die solche Filme
Ich hatte eine in der
Berufsschule bei mir.
Wobei die
nicht wirklich
da als Darsteller mitgewirkt hat.
Hat sie
zumindest gesagt.
So.
Also Chat, was findet ihr schöner?
Was findet ihr schöner?
Machen wir mal hier irgendwie
var list gleich
new
also Liste
eine Liste mit ins drinnen, okay?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Wobei man sagen muss,
das kann man mittlerweile sogar besser schreiben.
Man kann ja mittlerweile glaube ich sogar
kann man nicht mittlerweile sogar
das hier schreiben.
Und dann muss man vorne sagen
list
int
Ja, das geht mittlerweile auch.
Also sagen wir mal, ihr habt diese Liste.
Was findet ihr schöner?
Das hier?
Also mal angenommen, ich will das filtern.
Mal angenommen, ich will das filtern.
Vor, na gut, komm.
Machen wir mal for each.
Wir sind immerhin sicher.
For each
Liste, keine Ahnung, i
So, und wenn jetzt
if
What the, geh mal weg, Rider, Alter.
If i größer 2
dann hier keckel.
Ne, oder dann hier, jetzt müssen wir
jetzt müssen wir eigentlich tatsächlich nochmal
eine neue leere Liste anlegen.
Result gleich new
Lists
int
Result add i.
So, das ist der go way,
das zu machen.
Findet ihr das, oder?
Jetzt kommt ne ordentliche Alternative,
die ich ja persönlich viel schöner finde
und die meisten anderen Sprachen auch
unterstützen. Man könnte auch sowas sagen wie
Ja, war Result
Result, ich kann ja tippen heute.
Result 2, könnte man auch sagen hier
List Punkt
Where
Moment, das hier noch nicht mal brauche an der Stelle, weil
C Sharp da relativ elegant ist.
X größer 2
So
Was ist schöner?
Das oder das?
Die Go Entwickler sagen eindeutig das.
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung das.
Ja in Python List Comprehensions
da musst du irgendwie
so Zeug machen.
Das krieg ich aus dem Kopf nicht hin.
Also ich glaube wir können uns alle universal darauf einigen,
dass das hier die elegantere
Variante ist.
Vor allem, wenn man sie in Kombination
Das erste verstehst du,
das zweite nicht. Ernsthaft?
Findest du das nicht
relativ
quasi fast 1 zu 1
lesbar wie in englischer
Sprache aus der Liste
wo alle Elemente
größer als 2 sind.
Das zweite ist, ernsthaft findet ihr
das, kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
dass das irgendjemand
besser findet. Übrigens
Rider schlägt einem das ja auch vor, wenn man das so schreibt.
Guck, Convert to Link Spread. Ja gut.
To List, ja ist gut.
Chatge, gute Frage. Das können wir abstimmen.
Ja, was ist schöner?
Es hat glaube ich kaum
mal einer gesehen, dass es überhaupt einen Poll gegeben hat.
Aber es ist mal wieder 50-50 ausgegangen.
Das zweite muss so ein bisschen...
Übrigens
jetzt mal was anderes, wo man es auch richtig
schön sieht, wie praktisch solche
Sachen sind. Überlegt euch mal,
ihr wollt ein If machen. If
List Any
Element
ist größer als 2.
Und dann irgendwas.
Ich finde, das ist super angenehm schön lesbar.
Ja, ich...
Eine Sache lasse ich gelten, Chat.
Man muss sich minimal
mehr Syntax merken.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass es
so oder so ähnlich in anderen Sprachen
schon gibt, halt bloß diese Funktionen halt
nicht dafür da sind.
Also ich finde das zweite eindeutig hübscher.
Ja, man
kann es auch übertreiben, natürlich kann man es
übertreiben.
Aber das ist kein Argument dafür, das wegzulassen.
Ah, oder Sort
oder sonst was. Gibt ganz viele Sachen.
Ja, so.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, dass ich
das mal wieder lösche, sonst...
Wobei das, was ich hier gebastelt habe, das ist eh nicht mehr aktuell.
Ja, gut,
C++, lassen wir das mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich jetzt hergekommen
bin bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Zumindest sehr nices neues
Feature in C Sharp 13.
Extensions,
die mehr können als die
klassischen Extension Methods.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf.
Wie gesagt, eines der Dinger,
wo ich denke, dass C++
da wirklich richtig
big von profitieren könnte,
wenn sowas
da eingeführt
werden sollte. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das
passieren wird, weil das C++
Gremium macht lieber irgendeinen
Bullshit und führt wahrscheinlich
noch eine zweite Bedeutung für irgendwelche
Sonderzeichen ein oder sowas.
Der Witz ist, C++
würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das hier irgendwie
äh...
gültiger Syntaxcode wäre.
Meint ihr, das ist gültiger
C++ Syntax?
Also
realistisch betrachtet, nein, ist es nicht.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht allzu weit
weg von gültiger C++ Syntax.
Bisschen was von nem Fisch hier.
Legacy Coder
sollten vielleicht ihr Hirn updaten,
nicht mehr ganz so Legacy zu sein, wenn
Ray.Filter schon
das Hirn überlastet.
In JavaScript gibt es tatsächlich sowas.
Was?
In JavaScript gibt es Filter, ja.
In JavaScript
kannst du sagen Filter.
Filter kannst du in JavaScript
sagen. Das probieren die
doch seit Jahrzehnten schon, es hat nicht
geklappt. Wenn,
wär gut. Das wäre mega
nice, aber ich glaub nicht dran.
Das wäre mal was
sinnvolles in nem neuen C++ Standard, das kann ich
sein. Außerdem, wenn es in C++
2026 kommt,
dann dauert
es mindestens bis 2035,
bis das überall implementiert ist.
Wir machen das, was PHP
macht. Das ist tatsächlich ne gute Frage.
Wie mach ich ein Array Filter
in PHP? Also wenn ich raten
müsste, macht man es
weder mit ner Vorschleife,
noch mit so ner
Überladung, sondern es gibt irgendeine
Filter-Methode, wo man als erstes
Argument ein Array reinsteckt.
Moment.
PHP Filter Array.
Ja. Siehste?
Dachte ich mir. Ja.
Das dachte ich mir. Das ist so ein typisches
PHP Ding.
Die haben gerne 30 Milliarden
Funktionen in ihrer Standard Library,
wo du dann irgendwelche Sachen rein und wieder rauskriegst.
PHP
ist schon hässlich. Also ganz ehrlich.
Ich mein, es ist
auf eine andere Art hässlich
als C++.
PHP ist zumindest irgendwie nur noch ne halbwegs
in sich konsistente Sprache,
aber eine, die mir optisch nicht gefällt.
So.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich
zu diesem Thema gesidetrackt werden
konnte. Wie bin
ich von, ich kompiliere
mein C Sharp für meinen DVB-C
Empfänger, äh mein Go
für meinen DVB-C Empfänger zu C++
und zu C Sharp. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
PHP
wird aber viel verwendet.
Ja.
Das ist richtig.
Ist das jetzt, also
auf was bezieht sich
das jetzt?
Java wird auch viel verwendet.
Irgendwie so. Ja.
Ich glaube auch.
Ich hab übrigens
den Z-Server
Typ auf Twitter
noch was geschrieben heute.
Ich vergesse
ja immer, wie schlecht Twitter
Xitter mittlerweile ist.
Man sieht ja seine eigene Antwort nicht mehr.
Ich hab das dem jetzt noch ein bisschen näher beschrieben.
Und er meinte ja das letzte Mal schon, dass er
das versteht und
das fixen wird. Also, sobald das gefixt
ist, werden wir weitermachen im Stream damit.
Ich hab ihm heute noch ein paar
weitere Sachen geschrieben. Noch drei, drei
weitere Punkte.
Vielleicht setzt
er noch was davon um. Schauen wir mal.
Machen wir ein bissl was zu.
In diesem Video möchte ich
Nein.
In dem Video machen wir jetzt nix.
Oh, Chat. Jetzt hab ich tatsächlich
eineinhalb Stunden ohne Punkt
und Komma, ohne Pause
geschwätzt.
Und das, obwohl ich absolut
Null
mir überlegt hab für den Stream.
Manchmal float es
einfach so
vor sich hin.
Oder 1,21.
Jetzt bin ich aber fertig
erstmal.
Jetzt hab ich mich vom Hundertsten zum Tausendsten
gehangelt, aber
jetzt ist es erstmal gut.
Magst du es ans Trinken erinnern? Sehr gute Idee.
Hab ich gerade gemacht.
Falls ihr irgendwas gesehen habt, schreibt es einfach
nochmal in den Chat rein.
Ansonsten guck ich mal, ob es neue Package-Updates gibt.
Weil wir sind unter Archlinux. Da kann es sein,
wir haben vor einer Viertelstunde geupdatet,
dass jetzt wieder Updates
am Start sind.
Ich hab beides mal
kurz ausprobiert vor Jahren, aber kann ich nix
zu. Wirst du eigentlich auch öfters
gefollowbottet? Nee, gefollowbottet nicht.
Ich werd bloß Nacktfoto
im Profil zugespammt.
Ja, klar.
Weil sich das zwischen gestern und heute bestimmt
so viel geändert hat.
Was hältst du von KDE und Plasma?
Meine Standardantwort
bei sowas ist ja immer Abstand.
Aber ich verstehe, dass
das eine ziemliche Boomer-Style-Antwort ist.
Da immer das gleiche drauf
zu sagen. Das halte ich heute nicht aus.
Also was halte ich von
KDE und Plasma?
Zur Ehrenrettung von KDE
muss ich sagen, ich mag
keinen Linux-Desktop.
Oder kein Linux-Desktop-
Environment.
Das einzige, was ich erträglich finde, ist
i3. Und i3
ist ja fast schon gar nicht wirklich
als Desktop-Environment
zu
bezeichnen, weil
es hat keinen Desktop.
Kann ein Desktop-
Environment ohne Desktop
sein?
Ist die Frage halt.
Das einzige
andere, was ich noch
irgendwie halbwegs
verkraftet habe über längere Zeit.
Die einzigen anderen zwei, die ich
halbwegs verkraftet habe über längere Zeit
sind einmal ganz ganz früher Fluxbox.
Falls das noch jemand kennt.
Und XFCE.
Aber ich habe seit Jahren
schon i3 und nur i3
exklusiv.
Ich spiele ganz viele Sachen. Was ich nicht mehr spiele
ist Call of Duty. Zumindest in letzter Zeit
nicht.
Sollte da wieder ein geiles
mal rauskommen. Eins, wo ich
das Gefühl habe, dass die Leute, die daran mitgearbeitet
haben, auch Bock hatten, ein Game zu
erstellen, was was taugt.
Was aber nicht passieren wird, weil
auch wenn es jetzt quasi
Microsoft ist,
ist Microsoft ja nicht irgendwie
der Heilsbringer in dem Bereich.
Deswegen wahrscheinlich
eher nicht. Ich spiele immer noch
Games mehrere Stunden am Tag.
Meistens. Aktuell
hauptsächlich irgendwelche uralt
oldschool MMOs. Offstream.
Weil warum soll ich das im Stream machen?
Fluxbox, Openbox und sowas.
Sway habe ich ausprobiert. Das Problem ist, dass Wayland
in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das hier ist ja nur VM. Guck. Da.
Und Wayland
funktioniert in der VM einfach nicht gescheit.
Letztes Mal
vor einem Jahr ausprobiert. Chat.
Wenn ihr wollt.
Ich weiß, wir haben hier einige Wayland
Enjoyers.
Wayland zum
3000 Mal in VM.
Und wir können es noch mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich vermute, es wird immer noch nicht
funktionieren. Ja, aber
die eigentliche Frage war ja,
was hältst du von KDE und Plasma?
Ich muss das in zwei Sachen aufsplitten.
Ich finde es enorm beeindruckend,
was KDE und Plasma,
nennen wir das mal KDE, was sie auf die
Reihe bekommen haben. KDE hat es wirklich
geschafft, einen halbwegs
konsistenten Linux-Desktop
zu entwickeln, der wahrscheinlich
im Auge der meisten Leute auch noch gut
aussieht. Und
sehr viele, wenn nicht die meisten,
Customizability-Optionen von
allen besitzt.
Das ist das, was ich an KDE zu schätzen
weiß. Ich persönlich
mag aber, wie ich schon gesagt habe, keinerlei
Linux-Desktop, außer i3.
Und i3 ist nicht mehr wirklich ein Desktop.
Wenn mich einer fragen würde,
ob ich KDE oder Windows
benutzen möchte, dann würde ich natürlich
sagen Linux und KDE.
Wie lange hast du gebraucht, bis dein ArchOS
nutzbar war? Nutzbar?
Definiere nutzbar. Bis ich alles
so eingerichtet hatte, dass es mir gefällt?
Nie. Ich bin nie
fertig geworden, alles so einzurichten.
Ich bastel immer noch dran rum.
Wenn du meinst, nach dem ersten Boot,
bis ich
eine grafische Oberfläche hatte,
dann
nicht lange,
eine halbe Stunde oder so?
Mit dem neuen Arch-Installer ist das
easy as fuck.
Natürlich vergehen dann noch Stunden und Tage,
bis das alles so schön eingerichtet ist,
wie man das haben will.
Ich habe das Glück, ich kann meine .files
von GitHub nehmen und
dann habe ich das mehr oder weniger.
Wobei kann ich nicht, weil ich habe
meine letzten Versionen
nicht gepusht, aber hätte ich
das gemacht, könnte ich neu installieren und dann wäre es
da und es würde einfach funktionieren.
Nächstes Weihnachten!
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was ist mit Ubuntu?
Ubuntu habe ich schon
lange nicht mehr verwendet.
Aus meiner Sicht
waren die coolsten Ubuntu
Versionen immer noch
Ubuntu mit
Compets.
Das war so
nice.
Alter, was ist mit eurem Wiki wieder los?
Compets war einfach so nice.
Das dürfte so 2010 oder so
gewesen sein.
Das war einfach so nice.
Ja.
Guck mal 1104, aber
noch lange davor, noch bevor die
ihren hässlichen Unity Desktop hatten.
Zeigt da auch mal was?
Alter, das ist das
langweiligste Compets Video ever, Mann.
Ja, sowas kann man mit Compets
machen? Tatsächlich?
Das geht?
Das war so richtig
futuristischer Hackermanship damals.
Das war so
die coolste Ubuntu Zeit.
Ja, Ubuntu 3D Desktop.
Ja, genau.
Erstmal den Lanz aufmachen.
Ja, genau sowas hier.
Das rüberflippen und die Fenster...
Wobbly! Wobbly Windows!
Leute, das beste Feature überhaupt.
Was jemals erfunden wurde.
Wobbly Windows.
Würfel zum Drehen, genau.
Das war die coolste Sache
an Ubuntu Desktop mit Compets damals.
Ja, hat er. Hat gesagt,
ich muss Punkt 1 und 2 angucken.
Punkt 1 und 2 sind ja auch die wichtigen
Punkte gewesen. Das heißt, wir können
wahrscheinlich demnächst weitermachen.
Ja, i3, wenn man
noch nie i3 verwendet hat, ist in der Tat
ein bisschen eklig.
Wichtig ist, du solltest ein Terminal vorher installiert
haben, dann kannst du
Metataste plus Enter drücken
und dann geht ein Terminal auf.
Ich glaub,
bei i3 kannst du am Anfang auswählen,
ob deine Metataste
Windows, die Windows-Taste oder Alt
sein soll.
Oder dein Modifier-Key, ob das
Meta, also die Windows-Taste oder Alt sein soll.
Welches Linux
empfiehlst du als Daily Driver?
Kommt drauf an, wie deine
Interessenslage und deine
Linux-Skills sind.
Für mich gibt es eigentlich zwei Default-Sachen
mittlerweile. Server
Debian.
Obwohl ich lange Zeit auf Ubuntu Server geschwört
hab, aber die haben auch angefangen
immer mehr merkwürdigen Blödsinn zu
machen. Und so ungefähr
zu der Zeit, wo die angefangen haben
in Netplan, falls irgendjemand
das nicht kennt, dem werde ich
das mal schon gerade zeigen.
So angefangen bei
17.10 haben
die Leute bei Canonical sich gedacht,
Netzwerk-Config
unter Linux
in einfachen lesbaren
Textdateien, ja das
geht nicht. Das muss in YAML.
Und dann haben die angefangen
Netzwerk-Config mit so komischem
YAML-Zeug,
um sich und
Netplan zu machen. Das war der Anfang
vom Ende für Ubuntu Server bei mir, weil
ich da nie großartig Bock drauf hatte.
Ich hab's danach immer noch ab und zu
verwendet, aber ich hatte kein Bock.
Ich hatte einfach
keinen Bock auf diesen Scheiß.
Ja, dann auch ihren Hang dazu
immer mehr in irgendwelche Snap-Packages
zu packen.
Zum Beispiel bin ich jemand, der auch mal
ganz gerne, und ihr werdet euch vielleicht fragen, warum,
aber ich erklär's euch auch gleich.
Ich installiere
zum Beispiel ganz gerne auf einem Server auch mal
einen Firefox.
Ja, warum könnte das dann sein? Warum sollte man
auf dem Server einen Firefox installieren?
Ja, zum Beispiel, weil man per X-Forwarding
will, äh, weil man X-Forwarding
machen möchte
und einen Browser braucht, um irgendwas zu
testen, irgendwas aufzurufen, wo du so direkt nicht
hinkommst. Also manchmal kann es
sehr praktisch sein, auf dem Server einfach einen
Firefox zu installieren und dann per X-Forwarding
quasi vom Server aus einen Browser
zu benutzen, der aber lokal bei
einem selbst angezeigt wird.
Und das funktioniert mit Firefox unter Ubuntu
nicht mehr, weil das in so einem verkackten Snap ist.
So, das sind so Sachen,
da habe ich dann angefangen,
Ubuntos Server den Rücken zu kehren.
Da ich persönlich noch nie ein großartiger
Red Hat und Fedora Fan war,
fiel das für mich auch flach.
Auch CentOS und sowas.
Ja, ich verdiene damit
indirekt mein Geld, weil im Business Enterprise
Umfeld ist sehr vieles Red Hat.
Manche haben keinen Bock Red Hat Lizenzen zu
bezahlen, die haben dann halt CentOS, wobei es
CentOS jetzt nicht mehr gibt, also sprich,
haben die dann sowas wie Alma oder Rocky
oder früher gab es noch Scientific Linux und so
Gedöns, irgendwelche Red Hat Nachbauten.
Aber ich benutze
defaultmäßig auf dem Server
Debian. Immer das aktuellste
Stable Debian. Fertig.
Das funktioniert einfach.
Daily Driver auf dem Desktop,
da hängt es ein bisschen davon ab,
wie viel Ahnung du schon hast,
ob du dir
Linux Skills aneignen möchtest.
Tiefgreifende.
Wenn du einfach nur ein System
benutzt, was du benutzen kannst,
dann nimm Linux Mint in der Cinnamon Edition
und fertig.
Das funzt, das sieht brauchbar aus,
das hat alles dabei, was du brauchst
und ist, glaube ich,
mittlerweile sogar auch auf Debian
Basis erhältlich.
Und dann ist gut.
Und dann sei happy und
benutze Linux und freue dich, dass alles funktioniert.
Wenn du Linux
ein bisschen besser kennenlernen willst
und wenn du viel customizen willst
und super aktuelle Packages haben möchtest
und riesen Package Auswahl
haben möchtest,
dann kannst du Arch Linux
verwenden.
Was natürlich, sind wir uns einig,
das beste
Desktop Linux überhaupt ist.
Und ein Vorteil hat das Ganze,
wenn du Arch Linux verwendest,
kannst du der ganzen Welt mitteilen,
dass du, by the way, Arch
usest. Das ist enorm
wichtig.
Also sobald du Arch Linux User bist,
ist es nicht die Frage,
ob du das kannst,
sondern du musst
zu sagen, du musst allen
erklären, dass das
Arch Linux User bist.
Max ist outdated und nutzt NeoFetch.
Ich hab extra
NeoFetch und FastFetch verwendet
und der Witz ist, mein NeoFetch
ist ein Alias auf FastFetch.
Outplayed Modges.
Ich benutze nicht NeoFetch,
ich benutze immer FastFetch.
Bleeding Edge Technology.
Meinst du NixOS?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Nie verwendet.
Nix als Package Manager
unter nicht NixOS
könnte Potenzial haben
für das
Installieren von Software, die es nicht
für das jeweilige Betriebssystem gibt.
Habe ich mich aber selbst
zu wenig mit beschäftigt.
Fedora ist doch ein gutes Mittelding. Ja.
Aber ich mag Fedora nicht.
Ich mag Red Hat auch nicht.
H-Top oder F-Top? Äh, C-Top.
C-Top.
Ne, wie heißt das? C-H-Top?
Oh, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Ne, B-Top. B-Top ist das Beste.
B-Top meine ich, nicht C-Top.
Wenn den Stream irgendjemand hört
und ich weiß, von was ich rede,
dann denke ich auch, Alter,
die drehen hier komplett durch.
Nicht C-Top, H-Top. Ne, B-Top.
Kennt ihr Butt?
Ja, das ist
Cat in Rust re-implemented.
Ja. Hermes,
ausführlich genug beantwortet,
weißt du jetzt Bescheid.
Warum sagst du immer wahr, läuft das heute nicht mehr?
Ne, läuft nicht mehr richtig.
Das wurde damals standardmäßig mit ausgeliefert
unter älteren Ubuntu-Versionen.
Und Compitz wurde
Jahre nicht mehr weiterentwickelt
und es gibt heute einen Fork,
der ein bisschen angepasst ist,
aber diese Sachen funktionieren nicht mehr.
Schade, ne? Wobei man ja eigentlich denkt,
dass Open Source Software
noch am wenigsten passiert,
aber tatsächlich.
Wenn du heute Compitz mal in voller Pracht
sehen willst, muss man sich tatsächlich
ein altes Ubuntu installieren.
Ich hab sogar damals
Compitz auf der Arbeit verwendet,
wo ich Azubi war.
Und ich hatte damals eine alte,
was war denn das?
Radeon ATI war das noch, ne?
ATI Radeon 6000
Gab's da sowas in der Richtung?
Oder 5000? Gab's ne 5600
oder so?
5076?
Ne, das war eher so ne Gaming...
Passiv gekühlt?
Ja, also, so ein Ding hatte ich
auf der Arbeit.
Passiv gekühlt. Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass meine Grafikkarte auf der Arbeit
gar nicht passiv gekühlt war.
Der Lüfter hing aber.
Und die wurde immer
unglaublich
heiß, wenn ich wobbly
Windows wie verrückt über den
Bildschirm gemovt habe mit Compitz.
Ich konnte quasi fast meinen Rechner
zum Absturz bringen mit Windows-Wobbeln.
Ja.
Das waren ganz billige Alternate-Rechner,
die damals mein Ausbildungsbetrieb
gekauft hat. Wirklich.
Die billigsten der billigen Rechner von Alternate
haben die damals gekauft.
Mit Gehäusen, wo du dich
geschnitten hast, wenn du sie aufgemacht hast.
Und die so wackelig waren,
dass sie beim scharf angucken
schon aus Sanne gefallen sind.
Und es ist ja nicht so, dass das Azubi-Rechner
waren oder so. Das haben alle so Dinger gekriegt.
Welchen Garmin-Radcomputer
benutzt du? Ich hab ein
Garmin
Edge 8...
5...
Was gibt's da? 670?
670? Gibt's das sowas?
840?
Ich glaube den da.
Ah, nice. Garmin-Seite.
Der sieht der Sache schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Ich sag dir, was ich hab. Ich gucke einfach mal kurz.
Ich hab den glaube ich bei Amazon gekauft.
Aber ich bin relativ,
relativ sicher.
Das Ding ist auch nur so semi-nice.
Ich hab den jetzt ja schon ne Weile.
Und...
Da auch... äh, okay.
Aber relativ sicher hab ich den.
Und ich habe da auch schon
wieder customised
ohne Ende mit custom
Apps und Datenfelden.
Wir haben sogar mal in nem Stream
ne Custom-App für den Garmin programmiert.
Also...
Es macht alles, was es soll.
Ja? Soviel...
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade mal
den...
Den Dark-Modus einschalten, dass das nicht so hell ist.
Ja?
Also, das macht
alles, was so ein Fahrradcomputer machen soll.
Aber die Navi...
Also Navigation ist scheiße.
Kann ich dir gleich sagen.
Wenn du dich davon navigieren lassen willst.
Fertige Routen reinpushen und die abfahren.
Gar kein Problem.
Navigieren mit dem Ding sehr abenteuerlich
und auch super hakelig
und un...
Ja, un...
bedienbar so. Das ist eklig.
Wie weit ist die
Custom-Garmin-App eigentlich?
Das war nur zum ausprobieren. Das wollte ich nie wirklich verwenden.
Also...
Navigation ist
kacke. Was gut ist,
ist, wenn man sich die Routen
darauf anzeigen lassen will.
Allerdings ist auch die Refresh-Rate...
Das war das Monkey-See-Ding, ja?
Ist auch die Refresh-Rate ziemlich gering.
Das Ding refresht vielleicht mit einem
FPS. Und das ist bei manchen Sachen
schon ziemlich eklig. Ja?
Gerade wenn der Weg nicht so klar ist wie hier.
Wenn du Wege hast, wo hier ein Weg
abgeht, da ein Weg abgeht und da ein Weg
abgeht und du wissen willst, ob du
auf den richtigen eingebogen bist, dann ist das
Garmin-Ding teilweise echt ein bisschen wirr.
Deswegen...
Was ich mittlerweile mache, ist folgendes.
Ich hab den Garmin am Fahrrad vorne
dran. Der ist für mich
rein als Anzeige für
das
Licht hinten. Also ich hab hinten so ein
Fahrzeug-Erkennungsradar
dran, was
ich aus habe, aber hab ich, ja?
Also ich könnte das darüber benutzen. Ich benutze
das hauptsächlich zur Datenanzeige, mein
Garmin. Und zum Tracken von
den Activities, dass sich das bei mir
in die Garmin-App synkt.
Also ich lass da so Sachen drauf anzeigen, ja?
Herzfrequenz,
Trittfrequenz, Geschwindigkeit,
wie lang bin
ich schon unterwegs, wie viel bin ich schon
gefahren und sowas.
Pulsfrequenz, so Zeug.
Dafür ist das Garmin gut. Besser als jedes Handy,
muss man auch sagen.
Für die Navigation, wenn ich
was fahre, wo ich keine Ahnung hab, wo es lang geht,
dann nehm ich mein Handy.
Da hab ich Komoot auf dem Handy.
Das Handy ist vorne.
Da hab ich so einen...
So eine Hülle fürs Handy.
Da kann man das quasi so
auf den...
So eine Schraube...
Vorne ist da quasi...
Da wo der Lenker dran ist, so eine Schraube obendrauf
mit so einer Halterung, kann man das draufklipsen.
Und dann hab ich mein Garmin
vorne mit den ganzen Daten drauf
und leicht dahinter ist dann quasi mein iPhone.
Und auf dem iPhone navigier ich.
Ich hab zur Not auch
eine Powerbank dabei, sollte das mal den Geist
aufgeben.
Und so bin ich schon
zig Wege gefahren, wo ich keine Ahnung hatte, wo es lang geht.
Komoot und Smartphone
navigiert mich viel zuverlässiger
und vor allem...
Ja...
Schneller, was die Displayanzeige
angeht, als das Garmin.
Ich benutze das nur
zur Anzeige von aktuellen
Werten, das Garmin.
Aber das ist ganz nice.
Weil das kannst du im Handy beispielsweise nicht.
Du kannst kein Endplus Zeug
koppeln jetzt mit deinem
iPhone und sowas. Das funktioniert nicht.
Also, gerade wenn du
einen Brustgurt hast oder
eine Uhr, die deine Herzfrequenz
sendet und die willst du
anzeigen lassen, dann geht das
auf dem Handy nicht.
Und auch die anderen Daten vom Fahrrad
ist schwierig.
Als reine Datenanzeige
ist das Garmin gut.
Und was ich auch noch sehr
nice finde, das Garmin
hat eine Anzeige
für Berge. Das finde ich tatsächlich
sowas hier.
Das finde ich viel angenehmer als die
Berganzeige von Komoot.
Weil die Berganzeige von Komoot ist gar keine
richtige Anzeige, sondern einfach nur eine Linie,
dass es da jetzt hochgeht.
Das finde ich cool.
Dass du so eine Anzeige kriegst, wo bist du gerade?
Ja, wie steil ist es aktuell
gerade?
Was kommt noch alles auf dich
zu?
Das schaltet automatisch auch so eine Climb-Anzeige um.
Das finde ich ist ein echt cooles Feature beim Garmin.
Das benutze ich auch
immer, wenn ich irgendwo etwas längeres
Bash hochfahre.
Was ich immer gerne ausprobieren
würde ist, aber ich keinen Bock habe mir
das zu kaufen, so einen
Karoo 3 oder wie das Ding heißt.
Weil das ist
ein
Android
Das ist ein Android-based
Fahrradcomputer.
Und davon würde ich mir hoffen, dass das einfach alles
ein bisschen schneller ist, weil das hat eine moderne
Vierkern-CPU drin.
Dass das alles ein bisschen schneller ist.
Und ich bin ja ein Bastler,
was sowas angeht.
Wenn da ein Android draufläuft,
heißt auch, man kann Apps
sideloaden. Und man kann auch Tasker
und sowas sideloaden und
den Shit raus
automatisieren aus allem.
Da brauchst du nicht mal Custom-Firmware.
Da ist halt ein Android drauf, wo du glaube ich auch
per USB Sachen sideloaden kannst.
Also ich habe schon Leute gesehen, die haben auf das Ding
Swift drauf gesideloadet.
Ist halt kacke.
Das läuft halt mit 5 FPS
oder so da drauf. Aber es läuft.
Erstmal TikTok drauf installieren.
Also das Ding würde ich tatsächlich mal
ganz gerne ausprobieren.
Leider beefed sich
dieser Hersteller mit Shimano.
Deswegen wird meine Schaltung
nicht direkt unterstützt von dem Ding.
Fragt man sich natürlich,
warum muss eine Schaltung vom Fahrradcomputer
unterstützt werden? Ne, muss nicht.
Die Schaltung funktioniert auch ohne, dass der Fahrradcomputer
das checkt.
Aber du hast beispielsweise Zusatz-Buttons
...
Zusatz-Buttons neben am Griff
vom Lenker.
Damit kann man seinen Fahrradcomputer steuern.
Aber dazu muss man die pairen können.
Also sprich, wenn ich beispielsweise
Display-Screens durchschalten will
auf meinem Fahrradcomputer,
da habe ich links und rechts
an meinen Griffen
habe ich einen Schalter, so einen kleinen.
Damit kann ich quasi ohne die Hände vom Lenker
nehmen zu müssen, Fahrradcomputer-Seiten switchen.
Und Shimano
hat keinen Bock auf diesen Hersteller
und hat den verboten, dass sie
die Möglichkeit einbauen,
sich mit ihrem System zu pairen.
Eigentlich richtig assi.
Es gibt Custom-Plugins, dass das trotzdem geht.
Wie gesagt,
die Schaltung funktioniert, aber
das Umschalten ist halt schon sehr nice.
Guck, man hat
wie heißen diese Dinge, SIT, STI
oder wie heißen die Griffe vorne?
Buttons.
Heute Laberstream, ja.
Guck, die haben Buttons.
By the way,
nicht oben, sondern innen.
Aber
so ungefähr. Die haben Buttons
und die kann man pairen mit seinem
Fahrradcomputer und dann kann man die Sachen
umschalten. Ja, und
Shimano bieft sich gerade ein bisschen mit dem Hersteller.
Das Problem habe ich mit meinem Garmin
nicht, der bieft sich nicht mit
Shimano. Ja, also so richtig
komplett
geil ist das Garmin-Ding nicht,
aber
er macht das, was er soll.
Also, wenn du einfach nur einen Fahrradcomputer haben willst,
der funktioniert. Du kannst übrigens auch ohne Probleme den
kleineren nehmen, gell?
Also,
naja, der kostet halt viel weniger.
Die kleineren tun auch.
Was ist seitdem schiefgelaufen? Du meinst
Compets? Warum Compets nicht mehr geht?
Compets hat irgendwelche ganz
weirden, oldschool Sachen
auf X,
X11 verwendet,
was heute nicht mehr richtig supported ist.
Deswegen geht das nicht mehr.
Compets war echt die Zukunft, ja.
Debian ohne SystemD?
Nee, nee, nee, auf dem Server ein richtig echtes
Debian mit SystemD.
Ich werde nie großer SystemD-Fan
werden, aber da kommst du heute
nicht dran vorbei. Oder du kommst schon dran vorbei,
macht aber eigentlich keinen Sinn mehr.
Ja, Netplan ist scheiße, nicht
Linux ist scheiße. Netplan ist scheiße.
Wer kommt auf
so eine Idee, YAML-Dateien für Netzwerkkonfig
zu machen?
Wir sind heute mehr YAML-Engineers als
sonst was. Muss leider
sagen, dass ich mit Netplan recht gut klarkomme.
Dann ist es ja nicht leider, dann
blickst du ja durch.
Ich mag's nicht.
Geht das dann auch ohne Grafikkarte im Server
mit X-Forward? Ja.
Brauchst keine Grafikkarte im Server.
Die Anwendung wird bei dir lokal gerendert,
aber sie läuft auf dem Server.
Übrigens, geht
mit Wayland sowas wie X-Forwarding?
Ja doch, geht.
Die haben ja, muss ja gehen.
Die haben ja so einen
X-Übersetzungsmodul
irgendwie drinnen.
Es gibt doch so einen
Wayland zu X.
Die Anwendung wird dann einfach sagen, ich möchte
auf dem X-Server laufen und
SSH sagt, ja mach mal X-Window auf
und dann macht Wayland irgendeine X-Session
auf. Hab noch Probleme
damit gehabt. Ja gut, Wayland ist der
Inbegriff von, ich hab Probleme mit.
Technothema hat ein
Android-Video gemacht.
Braucht der noch mehr Kubernetes-Cluster
oder wie? Reicht das?
Oh ne,
mag ich nicht.
Suse hab ich immer einen großen Bogen drum gemacht.
Meine allererste
Linux-Distribution war ein Suse-Linux.
Damals noch auf CD.
Aber das war noch vor der Zeit,
wo ich mich da so richtig drauf
eingelassen hab und Bock drauf hatte.
Ich hab das damals gekauft, auch installiert und festgestellt,
ey, man kann's ja gar nichts machen, wieder aninstallen.
Weil das keine Distribution ist.
Jaja, das ist schön, aber
ich mag trotzdem Red Hat nicht.
Wie gesagt, bei mir gibt's zwei Sachen. Desktop
Arch Linux i3 Server Debian Stable.
Das aktuellste Debian Stable.
Ja, ja, Debian Stable
ist LTS.
Also das LTSigste, was es gibt
im Debian Umfeld.
Nein, ich mag OpenSuse nicht.
Ne, benutze ich nicht.
Was nutzt du für eine Top Bar?
Das da.
Das ist
Bumblebee
Status.
Ist das. Das ist alles
Default bis auf den Timer.
Den Timer haben wir selbst
programmiert.
Das Timer Widget hier oben.
Aber der Rest ist Default.
Was ich da sehr nice finde ist,
wenn man
CPU Auslastung verursacht,
guckt,
dann wird das da oben angezeigt.
Verursacht mal so ein bisschen Random CPU Auslastung.
Dann kriegt man das hier oben in diesem Widget angezeigt.
Sieht gleich, okay, ein CPU Kern
ist besonders.
Mini
Hardtop.
Ja, ja, glaub so sieht es aus.
Bildet mir auch ein, sowas ähnliches
mal gelesen zu haben.
Da fällt hier keiner drauf rein.
Wir sind doch alles hier Linux
Experts.
Da führt keiner irgendwelche Fogbombs
aus.
Geh?
Würdet ihr nie machen.
Ihr würdet nie Sachen aus dem Internet
einfach in die Kommandozeile copy-pasten
und nach Bash pipen.
Was?
Welches Di2 hast du?
Hat das Versionsnummern?
Also das Fahrrad habe ich mir
letztes Jahr, ne stimmt gar nicht,
dieses Jahr gekauft.
Also wahrscheinlich
die neueste Sache, die es gibt.
Aber ich habe mir
das gleiche Fahrrad gekauft, wie ich
letztes Jahr hatte, was im Unfall
hatte und geschrottet ist
jetzt.
Also das ist halbwegs aktuelles Di2
auf jeden Fall.
Also ich habe ein, eine
Shimano
Shimano GRX
Di2
Ja
genau, das da.
Alter
dafür kriegst du ja fast ein neues Fahrrad, Mann.
Das, also ich habe
ein paar
Sachen da dran modifiziert.
Als erstes habe ich natürlich mal
meine Kette gewaxt, so wie das sein muss.
Nichts unanständiges.
Weil die coolen Leute fahren heute mit
Kettenwachs.
Erstmal alles schön entfettet.
Und dann habe ich
noch hinten die Kassette
ausgetauscht.
Von einem 1136
auf ein
40 oder 42, ich glaube 40.
Und das ist sehr
hilfreich gewesen.
Wenn man steile Berge
hoch muss.
Und ich habe so eine Strecke, die ich gerne fahre.
Die hat zwischenzeitlich 20% Steigung.
Jetzt nicht über mehrere Kilometer
oder so.
Aber immer mal wieder
zwischendurch
für so 50, 60 Meter
20, ey das ist krass.
Da bin ich, da geht so was von
in die Beine.
Und da bin ich froh, dass ich hinten
ein bisschen mehr Spielraum habe
beim Berg hochfahren.
Also ich habe
vorne 31,
Zähne und hinten 40.
Das heißt, ich habe da eine Übersetzung von
äh falsch herum
0,775
Damit komme ich dann hoch.
Aber es ist immer noch anstrengend, wie Sau.
Das darf man nicht
falsch verstehen. Also X-Forwarding
ist kein vollständiger X-Server,
der Remote läuft.
Das sind bloß ein paar X-Libraries,
die du brauchst, dass es funktioniert.
Mehr brauchst du glaube ich gar nicht.
Und SSH
leitet das dann weiter
und rendert das komplett lokal bei dir.
Also du brauchst keinen Remote X-Server
installiert. Du brauchst nur lokal
einen X-Server oder irgendwas, was
X-Protokoll spricht.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass es unter Wayland
ohne Probleme geht. Moin!
Hallo Loon2568
Schau seit
Jahren deine Videos, da ich schon ein gewisses
IT-Interesse schon immer
hatte.
Nachdem ich mich dann beruflich neu
aktivieren musste, habe ich im September
eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwicklung angefangen. Deine Berichten
sei Dank. Ja, so schön, dass du sowas
gebracht hast. Und bin bis jetzt
total zufrieden, dass ich das halbe
Gewissen... Ja, das heißt im Endeffekt
du bist jetzt, ja
noch nicht ganz, aber fast ein Jahr dabei.
Passt doch eigentlich
ganz gut. Ich habe auch letztes Jahr
bei einem neuen Arbeitgeber angefangen.
Aber im April.
Ich bin jetzt schon ein bisschen über
ein Jahr dabei.
Ja, aber nice.
Wenn das...
Wenn mein Zeug auch was bringt.
Ist doch mal gut, oder?
Nicht nur dummes Zeug labern.
Ah, ihr müsst mich schon wieder ans Trinken
erinnern hier.
Ich merke schon, trockener Hals.
Ja. So, machen wir mal ein paar
Fenster zu hier.
Was haben wir denn hier noch offen?
China-Chinesen-Zeug? Ja, brauchen wir nicht.
Nochmal gucken, was es für Package-Updates
gibt, weil Arch, by the way,
okay.
Nee, gibt nix.
Ja, funktioniert der?
Muss das jetzt mal checken,
ob der wirklich nicht funktioniert.
Nee.
Doch, der geht.
Der Discord-Link geht.
Chetke, geht der Discord-Link bei euch?
Bei mir geht der.
Bei mir geht
der Discord-Link ohne Probleme.
Was passiert denn bei dir bei dem Discord-Link?
Ich mach den an, da steht drauf
Sebaru invited you to join
Max FPS Wobblers.
Hä?
Naja, ich kann den mal hier reinpasten.
Vielleicht geht das, wenn du es
direkt machst, anstatt
hier drüber. Ah, okay, bei mir
lädt es tatsächlich auch ein bisschen.
Könnte das sein, dass
Sebarus Server grad ein bisschen ausgelastet ist?
Ich hab's gesehen,
es hat tatsächlich ein bisschen geladen.
Du kannst einfach den hier nehmen,
der geht auch ohne
Magic DNS
Forwardings.
Moin.
Ja, ich bin eigentlich fertig für heute.
Also, Chet, haben wir noch irgendwas?
21.36,
spätestens 20 Minuten
ist eh Bad-Getime.
Morgen muss ich
relativ früh aufstehen, dass ich
da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Morgen
bin ich ja mal gespannt, Leute. Das wird
was, ey.
Das wird was.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich's erzählen
soll, aber nachdem
ich ja seit einer Weile etwas
sportlicher unterwegs bin,
ich hab
mich für Frankfurt angemeldet
zum GP
Morgenlauf.
Das ist nix, wo man großartig rennen kann, da ist
eh zu voll und sowas. Und es sind
plus 5,6 Kilometer.
Aber
ich hab noch einen Kollege, der will mitrennen.
Und
wir haben ausgemacht, dass wir
morgen mal eine Proberunde rennen gehen. Ich
weiß allerdings,
dass der selber so gut wie
nix an Ausdauer-Zeug macht.
Sollen wir dich anfeuern?
Wubblos anfeuern, please.
Dass der so gut wie nix an Ausdauer-Zeug
macht. Der hebt ein paar
Gewichte, ja, der ist also recht gut
dabei, aber der macht halt null Ausdauer-Zeug.
Und er hat
zu mir gesagt, ach easy,
er peilt
Pace von 6 Minuten pro Kilometer an.
Und da hab ich ihm
schon gesagt, also wenn du wirklich gar keine
Übung hast, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass
6 Minuten pro Kilometer ultra schnell
sind, aber wenn du gar keine Übung
hast, ist 6 Minuten pro Kilometer
ziemlich, ziemlich zügig, ja?
Und er war so, ach easy Max, alles
gar kein Problem. Und da hab ich ihm vorgeschlagen,
wollen wir das nicht vielleicht vorher mal
ausprobieren, ob das so easy ist?
Und er hat gesagt, ja, machen
wir. Und ich hab vorgeschlagen,
lass doch mal nächste Woche probieren.
Ich nehm morgen mal meine
Laufschuhe mit und die Hose.
Kurze Hose.
Und dann gehen wir morgen mal 5,5
Kilometer rennen, einmal im Kreis
so an Main lang über die Brücke und zurück.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie easy
er dann 6
Minuten pro Kilometer noch findet,
von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Vielleicht überrascht er mich auch,
vielleicht ist er übelst
krass drauf und hängt mich ab.
Man weiß ja nicht, kann ja sein,
dass er da irgendwie
4,30 oder so rumflitzt.
Am Main,
nicht am Rhein.
Ach, was heißt das mit der GoPro?
Ich hab tatsächlich schon überlegt, ob ich nicht mal ein bisschen was aufnehmen soll.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall aufnehmen werde ist,
ich will demnächst mal 22 Kilometer
nach Seligenstadt rennen, von Hanau
und zurück.
Also das sind insgesamt 22 Kilometer.
Das nehm ich
mit der GoPro auf,
einfach, dass ich's für mich festgehalten habe.
Vielleicht mach ich dann auch ein Video zu.
Weil da muss man auch erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich denke, ich schaff das.
Ich glaub das weiteste, was ich bisher gerannt bin,
sind 14 oder
irgendwie sowas, 14
Kilometer.
Wenn ich nicht so schnell mache, krieg ich 22 auch hin.
Aber mein nächstes Ziel ist auch erstmal,
also ich hab zwei Ziele, was das angeht.
Ich will einmal die 22 Kilometer
rennen nach Seligenstadt und zurück.
Bei Halbmarathon Distanz und ich würd
einmal gerne über 100 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren.
Bei beidem ist relativ realistisch,
dass ich das schaffe.
Mit Streaming Rucksack.
Weil wie gesagt, ich bin schon 14 Kilometer gerannt.
Danach ging das ohne Probleme noch weiter.
Vom Gefühl her.
Und ich glaub das längste,
was ich mit dem Fahrrad bisher gefahren bin,
war irgendwie ein bisschen über 70 Kilometer.
Das ging auch.
Dann werd ich die 100 auch packen.
Ja.
Da rennen wir dieses Jahr mit.
Und morgen machen wir mal einen Probelauf.
Also ich bin echt sehr gespannt,
wie sich mein Kollege schlägt.
Nächstes YouTube Video mit Outdoor-Footage.
Ich hab mir ernsthaft schon überlegt,
ob ich nicht ab und zu mal
ans Fahrrad oder
irgendwie mir, keine Ahnung, an
an die Jacke oder so
eine GoPro hängen soll.
Und einfach mal eineinhalb Stunden
aufnehmen,
damit ich entspanntes Hintergrundmaterial
für ein YouTube Video hab,
was nicht Gaming ist
und wo ich erzählen kann bei.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
es ist viel einfacher sich auf
also, ne, muss ich anders sagen,
ich glaube, es ist viel einfacher
entspannten Gaming-Content quasi
sich berieseln zu lassen im Hintergrund,
als wenn man irgendwie durch den Wald rennt.
Also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise was erzähle
über eine neue Windows-Sicherheitslücke,
ja, ich zeig da ein paar Bilder dazu
und vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen Sachen,
die in einem Artikel geschrieben wurden,
aber dass im Hintergrund ein bisschen was läuft,
ja, ist, glaube ich, irgendwie
irgendein entspanntes Gameplay aus irgendeinem Spiel
immer noch, ja, nicht so anstrengend zu gucken,
wie wenn ich im Hintergrund durch den Wald renne.
Downhill die Alpen,
das wirst du bei mir nicht erleben, ja.
Auch viel zu weit weg, ja.
Ich glaube, das schnellste,
ich glaube, meine Garmin-App
hat keinen Geschwindigkeitsrekord,
aber ich glaube, das schnellste,
was ich bisher je gefahren bin mit dem Fahrrad,
waren irgendwie, ich glaube,
53, 54 kmh.
Und da habe ich gedacht,
mein Fahrrad geht gleich kaputt.
Natürlich geht das Fahrrad nicht kaputt,
aber,
ich hatte
zu viel Schiss,
schneller zu fahren.
Und das war eine einfache Straße.
Das ging den Berg runter,
komplett geradeaus,
ich bin die Straße hochgefahren,
ich wusste, die hat keinerlei Schlaglöcher oder sowas.
Komplett geradeaus,
fast neue Straße,
also die einfachste Sache
überhaupt.
Und ich bin runtergefahren,
hab mir gedacht, okay, hier,
hier geht's richtig, auch relativ steil,
vorher bin ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
frag mich nicht, 45 Minuten oder so hochgefahren
und dann runtergeprettert in 5 oder
was auch immer. Zumindest
ich runtergerollt, hab mir gedacht, ey,
geht richtig gut ab. Dann hab ich einfach mal
komplett runtergeschaltet und noch ein bisschen
reingetreten. Und bei
bei 50,
52, 53, da hab ich
mich nicht mehr getraut.
Ich hätte, glaube ich, auf dem allerkleinsten
Gang noch ein bisschen mehr rein, ich hab mich nicht mehr
getraut.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl, dass mir gleich die Gabel
vom Fahrrad fällt oder sowas, bei
jedem kleinen Huppel.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die bei
Tour de France da teilweise 90
oder über 100 kmh da runterfahren
und in den Kurven sich
reinhauen, als könnten
sie, gut, was heißt als könnten sie,
ich wollte gerade sagen, als könnten sie beim
kleinsten Fehler gleich einfach sterben,
muss man sagen,
ist ja sogar vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
bei der Rundfahrt passiert.
Da ist einer über die Brüstung gefallen und irgendwie,
paar hundert Meter den
Abhang runter.
Also das verstehe ich nicht, wie man
das hinbekommt.
Du bist mit 40 kmh
den Berg hoch,
ja, aber nicht auf dem Fahrrad.
Zumindest nicht mit deinen Beinen alleine.
Was für ein Berg.
0,5% Steigung.
Achso, hat das Schwung, okay.
Ja, okay, jaja.
Verstehe.
Weil ansonsten ist das...
Nein, mach ich nicht.
So professional bin ich nicht,
dass ich mir die Beine rasiere.
Habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Das professionellste, was ich habe,
dass ich wie ein
richtiger Cyclist
aussehe, ich habe ein paar
Bib-Hosen,
also so Hosenträger, Dinger
mit einem Polster am Bobbes,
weil ansonsten ist das einfach zu
unangenehm, längere Zeit, paar Stunden
auf dem Sattel zu sitzen.
Ja, und manchmal, wenn nicht ganz so geiles Wetter ist,
habe ich so eine gelbe
Warnweste,
die ich drüber ziehen kann.
So eine schweißdurchlässige,
dass man mich auch sieht.
Aber ansonsten sehe ich wahrscheinlich auf dem Fahrrad
nicht übertrieben Cyclist-mäßig aus.
Also ich habe weder so
coole Carbon-Socken, oder was die da haben,
also
es gibt doch so Spezial-Fahrradsocken,
so extra aerodynamisch und sowas.
Habe ich nicht.
Ich habe
auch keine
super teure Brille.
Ich habe eine Brille, weil ohne Brille kannst du nicht fahren,
kriegst laufend was ins Auge.
Ja.
Ich habe keine komischen, teuren
Performance-Boosting-Gels und
und
Was ist, wie heißt dieses neueste Zeug,
was die sich da immer reinhauen?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich nicht.
Das einzige, was ich habe ist,
ich habe eine Flasche Wasser dabei
und ich habe ein paar Müsliriegel dabei.
Das reicht.
Der ist Open Source.
Fragt den Max.
Der Source-Conform-Stream-Archiv, der ist Open Source.
Der ist auf Shithub am Start.
Ich weiß das Repo aber nicht.
Aber das ist auf Github, das Archiv.
Weiß nicht, ob alles
bis ins letzte Detail auf Github ist,
aber das meiste schon.
Also diese AI-Generierungssache
weiß ich nicht, ob die auf Github ist.
Vielleicht würde der Max geheim halten.
Weil AI und Big Stonks
hast gefunden. Okay, nice.
Hier ist das Wubblos-Archiv.
Excellent.
Ich finde es aber gut,
dass du selbst deine eigene Readme kopierst.
Dann muss ich mich nicht mehr so schlecht fühlen,
dass ich deine Readme kopiert habe.
Eigentlich super advanced, ja.
Og.
Okay, Leute.
Bettge.
Wenn es sonst nichts mehr gibt.
Bettge-Time.
Also, macht's gut.
Katzenvideo.
Welches? Das da?
Nee.
Windows 15, ja, ist klar.
Ich sehe kein Katzenvideo hier.
Ja, das ist
dieses Miniatur-Eisenbahn-Ding
mit den Katzen. Ja, das kenne ich.
Nächstes Mal wieder Katzenvideos.
Bis dann, Leute. Wir hören uns.